hey guys welcome back to another episode
of h3 after dark
uh a little bit of a shaky start for
those of you who are just watching the
vod
we started the show
so is this the same page now or is it a
new page new page now it's a new url new
everything right this is such a train
wreck you guys
so this is the most train wreck episode
ever
so i tried my best to be on twitter
sponsors today nope okay
good i'm going crazy
they're not no one's gonna want to
sponsor this episode
so i tried i woke up early because you
all hold this you hold me ransom with
these foot ratings i even saw an old
cop's message from you saying hurry yeah
me
and i was like i'm on time no not you
because dan didn't oh
he didn't prepare
oh i sent it to you
oh no i thought it was to me dan or
someone on the team is supposed to
prepare a live now thing for me to post
on socials i was here ready to go at 12
15 and dan is over there who i call
littlefinger aka littletoe
who's who is literally conspiring
against me you guys have to understand
is conspiring against me
your foot general everything i've done
to tank my score how do i know that
first of all how long does it take to
post a photo dan's over there it's 12
15. i was like dude we got to go live
he's like oh gotta find the photo he's
sitting there it's like you don't know
exactly where that photo is dan it's in
a folder i was going to get it yeah why
wasn't it there it literally took like
15 seconds
is everything
dana was late dan was the bottom line
and then so i got so upset because i saw
the chat was going like take the feet
take the feet and i was like and i
screamed obscenity the f word which if
you say the f word in the first 30
seconds of the video youtube's like this
guy
and they maturate it they demonetize it
nobody sees the episode so we're like
you know what let's just restart
because it's just five minutes in
and here we are dan right
so guys can i please i'm begging you
please to everyone who's given me a one
star to please go back i was on time
today
i think i deserve a five uh
seven star rating and love if you see
anyone saying tank defeat you you have
my permission to permanently ban them
got it
permanent bands for anyone talking about
but what if you don't know what feet
they're gonna tank because now like they
know which tank defeat they're thinking
and i'm just saying dan also has a page
on wikifit now so
if they say tank defeat i invite them to
tank those feet
yeah okay so then dan also little toe
who's been conspiring all week exactly
he goes oh this isn't my foot and we
found out this is his foot because some
super sleuths actually went to like the
pits of hell and back to find this photo
it's incredible
and if there's feet on the internet
these guys will find it they're scary
man
these guys who fan dan's feet i wish
they would like investigate epstein's
death or something
we gotta put these guys to good use man
they're like incredible investigators
i hope people come back and watch
because that was such a cluster i think
they came back we're at 20 thousand yeah
the viewership is is there they came
right back
yeah they marched right back to the new
link i don't think we've ever done that
though in our like five years of doing
the show
is like nope restart
oh so wait there was a lot a new photo
well okay so this one you can't deny dan
that's you caught red footed it could be
some other bearded guy that's ended in
our office how is it possible that he
was walking around barefoot in our
office true
i almost feel like he did something here
to doctor
a picture all of a sudden
why are you barefooted dan no question i
don't i don't know
well what even is that i mean like what
what is that photo
that's like in the background i'm
assuming something could be from one of
those like uh handheld shots we did you
know yeah i used to show up with sandals
i think you just took off your scene
yeah
i was chilling man
i didn't know how could i know a few
years later this would be a whole
[ __ ] thing
well anyway listen i like it
dan is up here and you're all mad at me
meanwhile look at the number three spot
look at these [ __ ] photos there's
like a whole new set wait what is that
look there's a whole new set of ab
photos maybe
look no comment from me find yourself i
don't want to dogpile on a b because
apparently everybody is
but i mean for a guy who's not trying to
contend with my title there are a lot of
new photos
[Laughter]
you know the other guys the other guys
don't put out any videos i mean that's
all it is they don't post
i post what are you talking about i just
don't want to show my here we go yeah
okay let's not let's not get into it
right away at the beginning last episode
if you guys didn't watch we have a lot
of great stuff today
other than arguing about feet pictures
today carlos from big connect is calling
in the carlos so guys
i'll deliver when i hear it
i've been trying to get a hold of carlos
basically in my whole adult life
so we finally got him plugged in and
he's calling in i have a lot of
questions for him like hey
did you have that sound bite about what
he said about to his wife like my wife
don't even believe in me
i want to know about his marriage
doesn't believe in me
i'm really curious about the status of
his marriage me too
um ben shapiro was also calling in a
little bit later to discuss the twitch
hot tub phenomenon so he's a regular now
on the show yeah well you know he's got
a lot of uh
opinions he's got a lot of opinions
about the the hot tub phenomenal right
yeah
wet ass p-word yeah yeah
but they literally do have wet-ass p
words because they're in a hot tub
oh right like technically you can't just
use not thinking about that but i mean
yeah extra large and extra hard
um i do want to say
touch on the little
if you guys saw the last episode we did
it was a it was dripping oozing and
drama and controversy because zach
was upset that ab got the chair
that razer gave us
now i will say that there's an update
there's a little bit of a resolution
ab decided that the chair does not fit
in his apartment it's too big for his
apartment and so he handed it down
to zach
well that's very with very kind you're
welcome
wow very kind of him
uh very kind of you ethan anyway uh to
even offer you know buying me a new
chair which was you know totally
unnecessary but um zach you seemed a
little down the comments were very
brutal on you i'll say they were done
they beat the [ __ ] out of me
there was a hashtag
there was a hashtag firezak
maybe one person
they really beat the [ __ ]
yeah they weren't happy with zack they
thought he was throwing a hissy fit
well zach let me ask you this i just i
mean not not to stir the pot but um
do you of course do you think open the
lid and take a look at the pocket i'm
look taking a look i'm giving it a smell
i mean abe gave it to you because he
didn't because it didn't fit his
apartment is that really gracious of him
because he wasn't
i mean you know it's like dropping it
off at a junkyard right
so i mean i'll take it you know did you
already get it or not yet no i i still
have to go pick it up there's no winning
there's no winning he's gonna you gotta
go pick it up
you should [ __ ] bring it to me
i'm [ __ ] right mr mister
over here with his shade
i gotta drop it off now too yeah you
gotta drop may i make a request too oh
eel is coming out i would like to demand
that a b himself
uh delivers it
really what you're doing
i had a very interesting um
observation because i was the one
handing the chairs
and so i noticed that lina picked it up
for a b
and then sam picked it up
i thought it was for ian but i guess it
was for him yeah
but it is interesting
go ahead
that we got girl power here so the
ladies are things to pick up the huge
heavy objects on behalf of the guys
interesting
thoughts
even ela i don't know i can't i can't
argue no more even illas turned her back
on me i mean
well because look at you you're mr hot
tub with your shade okay all right
can you show your shirt can you show
your shirt you're as fake as that
leather jacket you're wearing bro you
want to show your shirt you
this is called embracing the meme
it says clout goblin
well you are in a hot tub is that
see-through can i see your nips through
that white shirt
let me see your name i think so
yeah i see i see the outline oh yeah i
see the name yeah yeah yeah
nice i'll tip your ass
i'll throw you some what are they
calling bits yeah [ __ ]
i'm gonna take some bits for those
little bits
i said after you tipped me do i have to
give the tips to zach
is he your pimp
he's got to pay the house he's never
satisfied i gotta bring him to work i
gotta go yeah i know that clout is the
water cold
it's extremely hot huh like i had i came
i got in and i jumped out almost fell on
the floor yeah well you just put in hot
water in there yeah and i didn't notice
how hot it was were you how did you feel
it you just took from like the kitchen
with uh yeah hot water
how what's your plan on emptying it the
same way probably just scooping it out
i'll figure it out when i get there wow
not sure
i hope there's no leak in that man i'm
scared for you
man i wish i was a hot girl kind of like
it seems fun just to get in a hot tub
and be like let's go
but nobody's gonna tip me for that i
could try
you should try you know i'll go live in
a hot tub
is there a jacuzzi you guys have a
jacuzzi yeah yeah let's do it evening
you're in evening with ethan klein yeah
hang out in the kitchen
i think it has quite the same appeal
maybe i want to say that um
i um
i support you i support ab i'm coming
out and i'm saying that i support abe he
gets a lot of [ __ ] from everybody
and um even though he is a bit of a
clout goblin we love him for everything
for everything else
that he does thank you god bless
you
are you saying that to try and make me
mad
zack
no i'm not saying that to make you mad
i'm saying that because yeah
everything's about zach no i'm i'm
saying it because
you are man your narcissism skill is
showing
right zach is on edge today yeah you're
on edge a little bit
well you um no i'm saying that because i
have been reading the comments and i
think they're right that we dog pile on
ab maybe sometimes too much
and um
you deserve you are worthy of a chair
you deserve a chair
and if it didn't fit in your apartment
and grotesquely and then you were if you
weren't just going to throw it out
otherwise just give it to zach
then
i would buy you a chair any day
thank you that's very sweet
just want to say i do love abey yeah i
want to say in zach's defense too before
we move on i won't talk about this too
much but zach is going through a very
stressful move
and uh
he's moving out on his own he's a big
boy
he's leaving his parents house and we're
all very proud of him
thank you i i do appreciate that all
right enough
it's not easy
did you guys know this tell me if
anybody knew this you know when you
brush your teeth you're supposed to spit
out the toothpaste and then the leave
you're not supposed to rinse your mouth
with water you're supposed to leave the
toothpaste what i never heard of where
to go
does anybody do that does anybody do
that no i definitely rinse it out no no
it's really disgusting but i've started
doing it that's what the dentists say
you're supposed to brush spit leave zach
what did you say not zach love
what is it yeah i've always done that
you've always done that yeah
and sweden they're ahead of everybody i
had a feeling they're more developed
yeah they're just more developed
how's your teeth you have cavities love
nope there you go of course fascinating
you eat lots of sweets
no i don't eat any sweets pretty much of
course
it's
man i swear to god i got a question so
you're supposed to leave it in your
mouth i thought you're not supposed to
swallow toothpaste well you spit it out
but you leave like the residue yeah is
it like it's disgusting
but it's apparently really good where
did you learn this little tidbit yeah
dentist like just recently something
different
yeah yeah i don't disbelieve you i'm
just yeah
before too and then
stop you you look stunning today dude
you posted these photos online stop i
was like what am i doing
your hair and your
eyes and
what do you call this schmutz hair
schmutz headband and the headband of
course and the vest that your mom made
you i was like oh damn you that
instagram picture let me pull that up
we got a vibe it cares about wikipedia
your mom made that vest i sent him a
discord said
my mom uh since she got here she likes
to have something to keep her busy so i
was like i i have an idea
um
oh i can't click it all right [ __ ]
is this
you have to be logged in here look at
this stunning [ __ ] so i asked damn
and then we work together and it's funny
because she was like you're making so
many changes throughout the
process and i was like welcome to teddy
fresh like that's right
that's kind of like what you kept
modifying her best yeah because
it was like you know things change once
you see it
but can you show this
um i'm sorry what
what a babe dude you look like a
supermodel
baby vin diesel watch your mouth
baby are you showing your ass now like i
mean come on dude tone it down look at
this
wait what because i need to still work
yeah i need because i need to reach the
keyboard so yes my ass has to float a
little bit to reach it okay
that's
what exactly
i was trying to fact check the
toothpaste thing
all right let's get on with the show
shall we
um
toothpaste clout goblin
this is a headline um either give me
your reaction
man arrested at airport after 35 birds
intended for singing contests found in
his clothing
sorry what how man arrested at airport
after 35 birds intended for singing
contests found in his clothing a bird
singing contest
it doesn't say what kind of singing
contest what is that maybe he was the
singer
oh and he's going to have the birds be
ringers for him yeah i can hope that how
many notices that was just a bunch of
birds they were alive
you know these guys are up to all kinds
of weird [ __ ] they've got like pockets
and then they like tape the bird speak
so they don't make sound he's like one
of these watches
yeah
definitely
he but don't worry guys he was released
on 25 000 bond that's pretty steep for
bird smuggling 25 000 that's pretty good
i mean
leave the birds alone right those dang
birds alone let them fly
um he was often entering into sinking
contests in brooklyn in queens
a special agent for the u.s fish and
wildlife service found in this elaborate
sting operation
in such contests often
conducted in public areas like park's
two finches sing
and a judge selects the bird determined
to have the best voice what the [ __ ] and
people are up to weird [ __ ] what
and this guy was so dedicated to this
bizarre finch singing contest that he
internationally smuggled well hold on
many who attend the singing contest
wager on the birds so this is like
this is serious business a fence who
wins these competitions becomes valuable
and can sell for ten thousand dollars
that's almost that's about uh one third
of his bond although special species of
finches are available in the united
states the species from
goyana are believed to sing the most
superior little yeah
there's guyana
finch folk songs oh he was being flapped
he was being paid three thousand dollars
to smuggle the birds oh wow
douches so there's another line of work
for you guys if things don't work out
here
i'm sweating what's happening i'm
coughing
are you hot the ac doesn't work today
i'm not
you're hot
you want to get in the kitty pool
so what time is carlos calling in
because i don't know if i should get
into this now or uh we said we told him
one o'clock okay great which is coming
up fairly soon so let's do a little
recap on carlos here
um
you guys probably all remember carlos
hey hey hey he's one of our most
frequently used soundbites although i
often wonder if we like him more than
the audience because he didn't fare well
in the soundbite competition totally
well travesty i mean yeah but the
competition was tough for him
yeah but i mean
i kind of expected a better show
but anyway we found him on twitter
someone suggested he reach out to us and
he said i'm down tell him to reach out
to me
he's actually apparently he's got a
vendetta against people online
he said if you were creative enough and
found the way to profit off creating any
kind of product bearing my name image or
brand simply get in contact with me i
would love for us to work together
instead of having to having you lose
everything by me taking legal action
against you you know he's got that big
connect money so watch out
i am so excited
well i think what he's talking about is
there's people making like nfts
of him and selling it so i get that
yeah
that's not cool
i'll have to ask him about that
here he is the original video
um we watched it recently but
[Music]
big connect is like um
was a crypto scam right dan what's the
background there yeah it was a crypto
scam um it was sort of set up
in a a classic ponzi scheme sort of
style where they got a lot of people to
invest in this coin maybe yourself then
there was
it was the
the big connect coin
damn why are you stopping me expanding
myself off not i'm on myself now well
you'll have to go behind the curve go
ahead thank you
anyways uh yeah the people who ran the
scam they uh ran
it up from like i think it started like
10 cents or something and it spiked up
to like 400
oh my goodness in a very short period of
time um and then
they cashed out on the scam and it was
sort of revealed and the whole thing
crashed back down from 400 to like 20
cents or something it's a bump
yes
the same thing's happening with this
other crypto moon
base i think it's called moon
the one that you sent that link of that
yeah stone dude
beware the same thing is happening right
now with the moon base what is it called
[ __ ] what is it called that crippling
moon something or other dude this one
crypto please nobody invest in this moon
[ __ ] it's called um
somebody tell me what it's called moon
moon shot or uh yeah it was something
done what is it safe mode oh yes safe
mode oh any
any investment with the word safe in it
yeah
the scam is in the title yeah
uh they're doing the same thing there's
like
this coin safe moon there's like a
hundred trillion of the coins they made
and people are buying like 300 million
for 200 bucks and they're like let's go
baby
safe moon to the moon
i saw dude say if safe moon because
there's so many in circulation if it
went up even one penny
to one cent in value it would have a
larger market cap than all of bit
bitcoin wait
because there's so many there's like
literally a hundred trillion of them
and so all these morons i mean well i
don't want to [ __ ] on them they're just
hopeful you know they're being scammed
so i feel bad for them but
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah everyone's going to lose their
money on that one but anyway so so
carlos
and all these people are all hyped on
big connect but it was just some people
who were gonna dump it all
right and they had all these crazy
schemes where they're like uh recruit
your friend that will pay you interest
and they were paying them out all these
coins and then everybody it was revealed
it was a huge scam and everyone lost
their [ __ ] so this is carlos before he
loses everything
which makes the irony so much
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey hey everybody my name is carlos
matos and i am coming from new york city
new york let me tell you guys that i am
so excited i am so happy i am really so
thrilled to be right now sharing this
amazing glorious
super and exciting moment of my life
with all of you guys
and let me tell you that we are really
changing the world as we know it
the world is not anymore the way it used
to be no no no
be connected
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
we are coming and we are coming in waves
we are starting and we are going to
actually go all over the world
we are belting the entire world
let me tell you guys that i started
137 days ago with only twenty five
thousand six hundred and ten dollars and
right now i am reaching one hundred and
forty thousand wait did he say six days
ago
no he said like a hundred and six days
ago or something like that yeah you
could get that kind of investment from a
lot of other things that aren't scams
[Applause]
anyway
he goes on and on we've watched it a
bunch of times but there's like some
really great moments where he's like my
wife doesn't believe him i'm gonna find
that part and let me tell you that young
actually earning around 100 i mean
around one thousand and four hundred
dollars of the corrections
i mean around one thousand and four
hundred dollars on an everyday basis
seven days a week
what
i am right now independently
financially independently i am saying to
so many people who said that this was
going to be a con artist game that this
was going to be a scammer game hey
you're going to lose all your money my
wife still doesn't believe in me
i'm telling him honey list this is real
no no no no that's a scam
his mic etiquette is pretty good i'm
gonna go to the bank i'm gonna get my
bitcoins i'm going to actually put them
into dollars here they are right on the
table
no that's money that you took from
another account
i'll say
what am i gonna do
anyway
so the legend the man the myth is
calling in at one
all right
he's also up to i don't know if i can
even show this tweet hold it be careful
dan but he showed it now i guess he oh
my goodness
apparently now he's a fitness trainer he
posted a picture of him naked on um on
his twitter account
very uh it's tasteful though it is taste
there's no dong it's a lot no there's no
dong i mean hey he's an old man dude he
looks good [ __ ] i wish i look like that
yeah
just taking it all in i wish i could
show you guys
um oh he has a youtube channel partner
with carlos is he still still doing up
to [ __ ] let's see what carlos is up to
on youtube
four months ago a picture of a car
his other videos don't even have
thumbnails interesting style
let's take a look this is carlos
matos coming to you live
guys guys guys i am so excited and so
happy
i am here
i am
tesla yes tesla tesla tesla oh he's the
crushing it
yep
he's getting a new car a new tire
he's filming everything along the way
you gotta love that
filming the sales guy
oh he threw shade at me eh
yeah this is actually fantastic three
years ago he threw shade at me how come
i never saw this
i don't know
apparently he roasted me because i i
don't if those of you who don't haven't
followed my whole career
i made a video about that specific video
of carlos on our main old main channel
h3 productions
he said can i come on your show ellen
oprah vince mcmahon they're like tone it
down try ethan
[Music]
someone said nobody could be on the h3
podcast he says is this a joke
is this pablo escobar during christmas
he's talking about yeah i mean that's a
good observation but what you don't want
to be on my show you're on it now i
didn't see a [ __ ] oprah or ellen pick
up the phone to call your ass carlos
okay
so we have bad blood apparently you can
confront him about that oh yeah you know
i hold on to a grudge pablo escobar and
christmas excuse me
i saw a comment uh carlos is hot yeah no
he looks good i'm not even gonna lie
dude i tap that i mean with peace and
love respectfully
someone made a remix
of him that he was not a fan of
next person that attaches my twitter
name to this video is getting blocked
again carlos you you're promoting the
video
yeah he needs to block himself should i
watch it or am i tempting uh well that's
just a screenshot isn't it yeah i know
but like we can find it we have the
technology
i don't know why he's
not a fan
yeah big connect was a scam that
collapsed when insiders pulled out after
the coin had spiked to around 436
dollars holy crap
when the scam was revealed it dropped to
40 cents per coin ouch
my god
that's a loss of like 10 000 or
something
yeah and um by all accounts carlos was
uh he was he was the scammy not the
scammer oh yeah he lost everything right
he genuinely believed in bitconnect
yeah apparently the two uh in
masterminds were eventually charged by
security frauds how did that pan out are
they in jail uh you know i it was
tough to find info about this all i
could find were articles from 2018 where
they got indicted um
you know that's the i couldn't find any
follow-up of like what actually happened
well with these kind of uh crimes you
know the securities uh
it was in another country by the way
they weren't in america oh i'm surprised
well you know what was in australia and
i think the other was in india maybe
damn
i don't think i could be wrong on that
but but usually when like these really
high-end white-collar crimes they go yo
just give us half and we're cool [ __ ]
everyone else got scammed well again i
didn't know what happens in america i
can find any info about them actually
getting convicted so
and here is a tweet linked to my
document to a account that has been
suspended
no
it is um
oh it's carlos's account right um
yeah he uh he ended up getting banned
from twitter recently uh i don't think
super recently oh hey it's me
but like those tweets that we were just
looking at of him uh goofing on you or
whatever that account's gone
that's why those were just archives
well anyway he said and curious why he
got banned yeah i'll ask him yeah
probably
probably selling a scam
probably
he lost about a hundred thousand dollars
love to talk to his wife
very sad it is very sad it's really sad
i mean
it's on his fault he got taken for a
ride man yeah hundred thousand
he was seemed very enthusiastic very
genuine about his he's a great hype man
dude i'd [ __ ] i'd hire him just to
hype up teddy fresh
true
teddy
[Music]
is he available now we're a little early
uh
could be
um you guys want to shoot him the link
and tell him to hop on i already sent
him the link about 10 minutes ago all
right you can let him know you can call
him whenever
we got a comment somebody said uh
you all helped me uh this one's from ian
rust
you all helped me get through a really
hard last three weeks my dog kirby was
gravely ill having the podcast was a
treasured comfort he made a miraculous
cup recovery
after learning how to breathe and walk
again and it's the next to me right now
wow i love doggy miracles i thought it
was going to be a sad ending me too oh
my god i very much thought this was
going a different direction yeah
the dog lived that's amazing the people
can die let the
dog you know what i'm saying
we love kirby we love ian rust and i'm
so i get really happy you know it makes
me feel like i'm actually doing
something
yeah
it's hard to believe sometimes because
we just sit here and you know goof
around
and it's like
whenever someone says something so nice
it's almost hard to believe
i don't you know i have a hard time
accepting compliments i guess but but
what about i can't walk around be like i
am so poor yeah
that would be weird so it's some kind of
defense mechanism for keeping me losing
my mind probably but yeah thank you for
the kind words you know it means a lot
to me that we're able to keep you and
kirby uh spirits up and
wow what a legendary dog yeah
we're thinking about getting another dog
really
kind of no it's good i know it's like oh
they're just so cute yeah i just love my
doggies
more kids more dogs
right i'm like a mormon or something
just more
more creatures in your in your household
you guys need a cat no cats i'm afraid
of cats because the dog the doors are
always open the cat yeah that's what
scares me i can't protect the cat
you know what i mean and they're like a
lot of coyotes in this area for sure a
lot
we love you kirby
kirby is my everything
can we get a picture of kirby oh ian
rust
ian rust hit us uh i guess discord is
going to be the best way one of the
staff
come here zach
here's the the remix
as we wait for carlos the world is not
anymore the way it used to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is great
let's go
[Music]
yes
whoa
let's go to the moon baby
they connect to the moon
that's a scam
he just loves big connect with his whole
heart and soul
i mean if
you made a hundred thousand dollars and
that quickly uh you know
hey uh i think he might be oh yeah baby
carlos nachos
he's in the waiting room that's nice
that is not him
all right uh yeah just give me one
second i'll set it up carlos carlos
carlos i feel nervous like i'm having
the queen on
do you know this is like meme royalty
yeah
car loves carlos
uh i let him in
he should have the technology don't
see him he's got a model y so i know
he's tucked up there he is very no way
is that carlos
matos i see his face
looking down on me like a god
regardless are you there can you hear us
i feel like i'm watching um
i feel like i'm watching one of those
weird
streams where
wow this is odd
uh
carlos it says that your audio is uh
your mic is muted you're muted yeah i
don't see him trying to talk though
can you hear him looks like he's in the
same room
carlos did you hear us okay can you hear
me
yeah i can hear you guys just fine
okay
carlos what an honor to have you with us
well the owner is mine
well are you aware i mean i don't know
if you followed my coverage of the whole
big connect thing have you
i don't know is there bad blood between
us do you have something that you want
to get off your chest to me
i i
have no bad blood with anybody i'm
loving okay person who just believes in
you know expanding my mind all the time
i just wanted anything you have ever
said to me you know anything that you
have ever said about me in the past
hey no problem
we love that
have you been able so tell me first of
all
how
how did your wife i just i'm sorry to go
back over this dramatic stuff probably
it's probably it hurts for you right to
talk about big connect i mean they got
you good
no it doesn't hurt me
not at all it was an experience
and i am somebody who welcomes
experiences
where
my main objective is to learn
and
bring it on whether it's good or whether
it's bad it's always good
because there is always a tremendous
experience that you can learn from those
failures that you have in your past i
mean how else are you going to be moving
forward
that's a good approach so what was the
lesson like what was your ultimate
lesson from going through the big
connect thing if there was one
yeah the ultimate lesson was to
take a very close look
at those
organizations
that you are getting yourself involved
and do a very very in-depth due
diligence
and anything that where you are not
dealing directly
with
the
creators
of that project
anything where people are
uh in obscurity and darkness
let's stay away from those things stay
away from those things make sure that
you can see eye to eye who you're
dealing with
and um
and also
do not ever get yourself involved into
any crypto currency
where there is a close market
where the market is actually being
manipulated and controlled by that
specific entity
you want to be in cryptocurrencies
that are openly being traded
in the very best exchanges in the world
listen that's a way that you can protect
yourself
that's smart that's smart advice where
where were you when you found out like
oh my god bitconnois big bit connect is
crashing to like 40 cents or something
like that you know
i i really didn't get much hurt um
you know from the bit connect experience
in terms of the money that i lost
i
was able to get my the money that i
invested out oh really what i did yes
but what what i did not get was the
profit
that supposedly i realized
which i
you know didn't have time to get
absolutely
it was just a bush and everything else
so you were you were able to like cash
out your original investment before it
crashed yes ah no wonder you're so zen
about it that's good
yeah but but in a way i am not because
i also do not feel
uh that there are people out there that
will take the experience the same way
that i that i take the experience see to
me
it is a blessing
bit connect was an amazing blessing
because i learned
so much from the connect
and he he got me into an amazing path
the path you know of growth that i am
right now because one of the experiences
that me who i am
did you ever have the moment where i
know you talked at great length in your
speech about your wife doesn't believe
in you she thinks it's a scam did you
what was it like when you had to be like
my dear wife
i bow to you humble carlos
yes it's absolutely true humble carlos i
bought you and i realized that i made a
mistake but guess what guess what though
i believe
that the fact that
that i was able to just go and
take the risk
um
that speaks value of my
being fearless does your wife agree
take it no she did not
agree at all and i and i you know and i
uh and i um
you know i i i respect her so you guys
are still we right now are deported
we have people oh you are yeah no longer
yeah we're no longer together
um did the big connect have anything to
do with it or no yes yes it had a lot to
do oh no the big connect i don't know
yeah but at the same time i'm happy that
that we are divorced because
i found out that we are just
people that believe in different things
and i think in order for me to grow
even more i need to be
uh on a train on the trajectory that i
am right now where i am
my own person who is created in my own
world
according to the things that i believe
carlos let me ask you how has life been
like when this whole thing went down
there was this incredible carlos meme
dumb i've seen you on twitter being like
yo people are selling my likeness you
better watch your ass because i'm coming
after you with my lawyers
and then also i've seen kind of maybe
you've been a little bit hesitant maybe
let's say to embrace your meme dumb
what is life as a meme carlos if you
could tell me in your experience
when i go into the streets of new york
city
uh there are people that are that
recognize me there are people that um
ask me for autographs it's like i am a
celebrity in certain areas
so in a way that i enjoy that
recognition and better understanding
um but the negative side of it
some people look at it as if i am part
of this um
you know scam
and that i was like one of the of the
people who
uh participated on scamming people
so
making sure that people understand that
i was not
one of the originators or one of the
masterminds of the
scam that i heard so many people across
the world is something that at times i
encounter and it's totally fine with me
to explain to people you know i
understand your opinion understanding oh
but hey i am now one of those people
that hurt you know so many people and
eventually people understand because i
was looked by the sec
and you know different
federal organizations did the fbi
comment come talk to you
um not the fbi but the sec
and and they uh you know they look at
everything they clear it and they're
fine i mean and i now have nothing to
hide shortly shorter than everything
that has to be shown and that's okay
and i that's important that people
understand that that
those people that were found to have
some kind of malicious intent
that was proving in the documentation
they were they uh you know got it they
went to jail some people went to jail so
people got into serious problems because
they were they were found to be guilty
of you know hurting people
but that's not the case and yeah that is
good to hear
are you um
are you into uh crypto what are we what
are we in now what's our portfolio yeah
i love i love cryptocurrencies i believe
that cryptocurrencies
is
an amazing avenue
for many people across the world to be
able to grow
um if you look at things like bitcoin i
believe bitcoin
is going to have a tremendous growth
trajectory
you see
the biggest
institution coming on
um
you know goldman sachs giving approval
that
you know bitcoin is one of the greatest
investments of all times
even
enticing their clients to go into
bitcoin
you see uh you know
gemini.com now bringing all these
different
amazing coins and so on
yeah i believe that people need to
embrace
the idea of cryptocurrencies
the innovations that are coming on are
absolutely incredible and amazing
and i think that this opens up a
complete new dimension in terms of
investment and there's going to be
lots and lots of people who are going to
become
very wealthy by doing this
and this is just the beginning we're
just at the tip
the very very tip of the iceberg
so how did they get you on that stage
i'm curious about like the workings of
like
because there were there was this big
event and you were on stage with the but
you were just like an enthusiastic
investor what was the logistics of
getting out there that was it that was
it i was just there they were
um they were actually having a group of
people giving testimonials of how they
felt about it connect
and i decided to you know bring my um
you know my fire oh yeah
my fire and i i am you know i am someone
if you put me on stage
you know i'm gonna bring the house down
i just have the power i just understand
how to deal with audiences
and
yeah i'm a powerful public speaker
and and i just have this way of
connecting with people and
um and that's what i did that's what i
did so
the
speech went you know viral
and you guys have seen the results of it
yeah
what other we got i'm thinking maybe
what what else are you passionate about
because i'd love maybe to get you on
stage to deliver another speech about
something you're really passionate about
what are your passions i
i love
i love um
working and helping our people i am
an aba therapist who works with autistic
children and their families
oh that's very i'm very successful
yeah i'm very successful about what i do
i have i have
changed
hundreds of children and hundreds of
families
lives throughout my 70 18 years as an
aba therapist
and i'm considered to be one of the top
you know dogs in the uh
in the arena in the area of
you know applied behavior analysis and
in dealing with uh children and their
families
and um
just doing that
i i don't even have to do anything else
but i'm also a life coach and i love
working with people unfortunately i can
only take seven people
and
most of the time i'm always booked so
when people want to go ahead and
take you know a live coaching with me i
i gotta put them on a waiting list and
the waiting list is about a month how
many people got on your waiting list
only right now on the awaiting list
there's like um 25 25.
you want to make it 2 500
oh well why not you want well so here's
what i'd love how about would you be
willing
i'm just spitballing here just thinking
off the cuff but if we could get you to
deliver let's re-race the history
let's do a new carlos
giving lu life the fire carlos bringing
the fire for the life coaching
and we'll play it on the show and plug
let's get carlos the life coach out
there can we get a new speech from
carlos not right now but we could this
is something we can work on to erase let
me tell you let me tell you let me tell
you something
if you put me on the stage
oh the flame right right
right
right now
if you put me on the stage right now
i will completely put the house on fire
well here i mean i don't need an admin
i do not need
to go ahead and write the speech
i do not need to prepare anything
i just start opening my mouth and i fire
okay carlos here
let me challenge you to this
we have 40 000 people watching
right now
40 000 people are watching right now how
many people are in that big connect
audience
okay
so put the phone so let's put the phone
against something
and let's get you're on stage dude
you're in the dodgers stadium you're in
yankee stadium
let's get a speech right saying let's go
there's uh all right so
let let me just just start to take it
let's say this
okay
this is to all of you out there
who are finding that your lives
are buried in mediocracy
in confusion
in despair
it's in a time
that you say to yourself
i gotta take control of my life
i gotta wake the [ __ ] up
i gotta say to myself
what is it that i have been doing all
these years
are you finding yourself in the position
in which i was at one point in time
that i was actually earning so much
weight that i got to
about 248 pounds
are you seeing that around you the world
that you're thinking of is not really
becoming the world that you wanted to
become
why not right now say to yourself why
not right now i better stop this
right right now what are you doing right
now right now let me tell you something
i have found i have found the way of how
to do this
i have been able to create
disciplines simple disciplines of life
that if you apply to your life every
single day
i can guarantee okay
and that is of course according to the
effort that you put into it of course if
you do put the effort into it your life
will transform itself and one day you're
going to open your eyes and you're going
to [ __ ] realize
that what you are thinking
and what is outside of you
is that red is a direct reflection
so the world inside you and the world
outside outside of you
become
one
and i have been able to achieve that and
not be able to
learn how to do that
and through the life coaching that i'm
doing
i'm taking
people who are really
in deep [ __ ]
that are finding
that they're changing their life
that's what i can do guys
bring it on let's go
[Applause]
there's that fire
wow
i'm heated up i'm ready to change my
life
whoa i'm wiping it here
let me tell you let me tell you i i
unless uh after the big connect i went
into a state that i felt
um you know going on a down spiral i
felt really bad
and i started gaining weight and
you know being completely uh
very unstable
and i started uh looking at myself in
the mirror and saying man
better stop this
and i started researching and learning
about lots of different things and i
found this powerful discipline
from
a few
different gurus people who were amazing
at what they did
or what they are doing
and what i did was i put those things
together
and now
in my opinion i have the [ __ ] keys
to go ahead and turn your life
on
and just make things completely
change for you so i'm highly blessed
highly favored wow so excited to be
carlos
carlos got the [ __ ] keys the guru
are you are you considering yourself a
guru carlos or not yet or what's your
status i do not i do not like to see of
myself as a guru i like to see myself as
a student right i always want to be
hungry
let me ask you this you said you've got
the [ __ ] keys are they car keys or
door keys
it's mine
monkeys
that's it
you see the problem with most people out
there is that 99 of the world
population
are actually being programmed
by all of this micro programs micro
mental problems by all of this mental
problems that other people around
are designing and creating
organizational companies institutions
and they're creating all these micro
programs and all this mental problems
and people are absorbing
that those mental progress each and
everything
and
the reason why is because the mind hum
the human minds were like machines like
we're like computers we're always
searching for an operating system so
that we can create the world that we
want to create but the problem is that
when people start going out there and
thinking those icons of programs and the
mental trainings from other people
they're not truly creating
their world
they're creating
somebody else's world who do not really
give a [ __ ] about them
and that is exactly
what's truly going on and it's not until
you learn
how to program your life
that your life will truly
start to change wow
oh i'm wiping the tears
away where can people sign up for life
coaching
oh what happened the best thing would be
for them to just
give me so the best thing
the best thing for them is to send me an
email to carlos matos coaching gmail.com
there we go okay your life starts now um
you know just be patient what's your
rate
be patient because
there is a waiting list
my real leader
rating is 500 hours an hour
there isn't three hours a week that
people
and there is a thousand dollars
commitment
carlos enlightenment ain't cheap
that no it's not that thousand dollars
commitment deposit
tells me if you truly if you're truly
truly truly right um
dedicated and committed
you gotta have that one gotta put the
money boom put it in carlo's hand no but
what that thousand dollars
i am not the one who's gonna supervise
you
to tell you what you did what you have
to do you are the one so by the end of
the week you say to yourself i did
everything
back
but it's at the end of the week you
yourself have the understanding that you
know what i [ __ ] up i really didn't
commit to what i had to do
you know the thousand dollars
for yours
it's up to you i am not going to be
you know looking at you're not paying
anyone
so it's a thousand
the thousand dollars is to get in the
door and then it's 500 an hour and you
set a minimum of 30 hours
of three hours oh three hours
i thought you said thirty thousand no
that's a thousand four hundred plus a
thousand that's two thousand four
hundred right
but out of the two thousand five hundred
only one thousand a hundred a week is
actually the training but the 1000 is so
simply the commitment deposit now let me
understand you get it back
is there a satisfaction guarantee with
that three hours in the deposit no no
there is no guarantee there is no there
is absolutely no guarantee that any
change is going to happen the reason why
it's up to them it's up to you right
now i thought you shared with me i'm not
your life
well what if they say well they say
listen carlos i know everything you told
me and like i just want my money back
fine then give your money back oh you'll
give it back okay good
just care i'm just curious on your
return remember one thing remember one
thing i am
um an aba therapist first right right
right right right and and i make you
know i make good money with that right
right
the the live coaching is something that
i do because i want to help people
to really transform their lives because
from their lives so at the beginning i i
work with people and i share with people
the things
that i believe are going to help them
and most of those people can you give it
can you give us a free sample like of
what people might come to see from like
the first hour
like where we will tell you yeah i will
tell you
in which the things consist the program
actually concerns there is a part
that is about mental programming
what do you have to do in order for you
to program your mind and that's the most
important thing right you have got to
first of all working online
so i go
on the specifics of what is it what you
need to do right
then after you do the mental program
there is another part in which you work
on
your energy
you see if you do not have energy if you
don't have vitality do you see the
reason why i'm so emotional
it's because i have tons of energy tons
of vitality my energy just powers
how how does it happen well it happens
because of certain breathing techniques
that i do
to help me to inject
oxygen directly
into the areas of
the cells that produce the energy
so when you when you're going to the
actual areas of the cell that produce
the oxygen i mean that produce the
energy by providing oxygen and you do it
on a regular basis mitochondria they
call mitochondria
there is certain things that you need to
do some breathing exercises that you
need to do okay
yeah after after that then there is also
especially
you need to stretch your body
now stretching is a very important thing
for you to do in order for you to get
your body ready for anything and
everything that could happen throughout
your day a lot of the reason why people
get hurt is because they don't pay
enough time to drink
i personally you know take an hour of
stretching every single day i stretch
for one hour and
it's one of the most amazing parts of my
of my day i really love it is there
something
i feel is there some kind of like
to fully enlighten yourself
is there some kind of like i will say i
will say that as you start doing these
things
i believe that you will definitely feel
enlightened because just the fact that
you're spending some time
to really program your mind
deep into who you are
what you want to do i've got a crazy
idea tell me if you think this is good
dan what if we did a three hour session
i paid you for it on the podcast three
hours just with carlos
or is that like is that like pirating
your [ __ ] would you not want to do it
live
uh no i would not like to do it that way
the fact is that you know
it will it would actually
you know
it will go
and and uh
it will not be good
so
so that's
the one thing so you do your your mental
programming then you do your breathing
and the yellow stretching
is there anything about do you know
anything about unlocking sexual chakra
well the actual the actual uh
you know part of the sexuality of both
men and women is really attached
to the directions in the flow of
energy right and the flow in the flow of
you know your blood
so if you want to increase your mental
power i mean your sexual ability other
men or women yeah you have to learn how
to direct the blood into the right areas
right especially on your genitals
is that something you can teach
yeah absolutely nice that's something
that i personally do as well and that i
advise every men and women to do if you
want to be
you know
sexually
uh powerful right
yeah
i mean i hope i'm not stepping out of
turn i feel i hope i'm not stepping at a
turn but i feel like you are sexually
powerful
can you comment on that i i i feel i
feel amazing yeah i feel amazing
i i can say that i feel amazing are you
with anybody right now
um
that area i don't want to touch on it
okay fair enough no problem i have you
know i have my
you know my uh my intimate life yeah i'm
very happy
how would you rate yourself as a lover
i'm powerful powerful that's what i
thought
you clearly have a lot to learn from you
uh carlos thank you so much for gracing
us
we've got the people have your email
they want to learn
from the uh the three steps yeah what
was the email one more time yeah give us
your give the people your email
the email is carlos
matos coaching
gmail.com
be patient guys there's a long waiting
list and it's going to be longer
wow yeah and i and i gotta uh thank you
for giving me the opportunity to be on
your show
absolutely that you have conducted
yourself um
very professionally oh thank you well
that's your lovely um
all right hey calm down with your sexual
powers over there carlos
come on don't get too powerful on me now
my wife
okay all right i'm just making sure
all right all right carlos appreciate
you thank you so much for calling
and highest highest of blessings nice
blessings back to you
a lot of success thank you a lot of
blessing a lot of growth uh continue for
years and years to come thank you so
much carlos thank you carlos keep those
choppers flowing all right buddy
thank you all right take care
carlos ladies and gentlemen carlos
um
legendary i'm i'm happy to learn first
of all let's recap there was a lot of
information exchanged
[Applause]
and we even got one of the
we did
one of the powerful uh flame
throws we sure did wow there was a
couple moments where his phone was
really
underwater
yeah
yeah
audio wasn't always the best but um well
i'm happy to learn he got his money out
me too i'm not surprised his wife
divorced him
but he sounds happy
my wife still doesn't believe in me she
still doesn't but they they've moved on
interesting they got divorced because of
the big connect that was an interesting
tidbit
yeah
sad
it sounded like it was definitely a
rough
moment there yeah
he looks good now though and like i mean
it's too bad he doesn't want to
this too bad he doesn't want to film our
session i thought that'd be interesting
well i guess i get it
i can't give away the secret sauce i
mean that's fantastic eh
powerful that was really powerful
i'm so glad we could finally get him on
this is interesting i knew he'd be an
interesting guy yeah
people saying uh carlos for the next h3
bachelor
oh
it sounds like he's in a relationship
though
true that's true it does
very confident sexually too i knew
powerful i knew he was a confident uh
sexual power
somebody reach out to carl's and see if
he wants a razor chair i'm sorry zach i
gotta send him your chair
i'm gonna give it to carlos yeah this is
razer chair is a new currency yeah razor
chairs are currency of the future
[ __ ] bitcoin
chairs
wow
wow
oh better than i could ever hope for i
feel like i just
reprogrammed my brain like you said
fantastic what do you guys see any
reaction in the peanut gallery over here
i've signed it up for the
lifeguards i don't
25 people are already ahead of you guys
so i'll pay extra to get a little bump
it does have a refund policy as well
which is nice
i thought he said he didn't well then he
came back i said listen i was like yo if
i know everything
okay can i get my money back he said
yeah you can get you can get your money
back oh that's nice
um
how do you move on for that
so i think i need to um bathroom break
ela
oh i'm we have to restart the stream
all right i'll set up the so next up
we're talking about the twitch hot dub
controversy
and we're actually gonna have uh ben
shapiro calling in the comment on this
at the conclusion
to provide us his insight
as he's always very insightful
so i guess you know there's i feel like
on twitch there's always these uh
i wish we could take some call-ins too i
feel like we need to debrief the carlos
thing a little bit
you know if we could take some call-ins
from the audience but
i don't know if anyone wants to share
their thoughts
anyway on twitch
i feel like there's always a battle
between the gamers and the gamer girls
on twitch you guys know what i mean go
home gamer girl there's like a strong
would you call it red pilled or because
there's all these guys are like i'm a
good gamer why are girls watching
pokemon just because she's got a fat ass
or so i don't know i'm not
i'm just saying i know that's the meme
about her it's like so thick right
that's the meme about pokeman oh yeah
i'm not speaking that turn right
yeah you can't even go on youtube
without seeing compilations of really
just of her like yeah i always see this
picture of her like just reaching over
and it's like these guys are so deep
deprived it's like she's literally just
reaching over to grab something and it's
just
it's she's wearing pants and it's just
you see her butt daddy and everybody
salivating over this picture like
it's uh absolutely [ __ ]
cringe
how would you do well love actually you
know you're probably the most familiar
with twitch uh culture right
among us
what's going on on twitch is it gamer
guys vs gamer girls
i mean to a large part yeah it seems to
be
i just want to add i don't watch that
part of twitch
watch the gaming part of twitch um
clear the air a little bit you say that
well because you're you're you're almost
making it seem like i'm a professional
on this topic
oh
okay you just want to say
right but you're familiar come on don't
play it down i mean you spend a lot of
time on twitch it seems like
love don't you have a pokeman out of
context account too
oh
no you wouldn't do that
the new the new thing on twitch is that
these girls set up hot tubs and they
just are in their bikini i thought
twitch had a policy where they said no
uh you couldn't be in a bathing suit but
did they loosen it or did nothing change
well that's that's what this controversy
is is sort of
like the
inconsistency of the uh enforcement of
because people were like oh like i
remember i was like taking off my shirt
for some reason i don't know why i was
like what or something and people like
oh you're gonna get banned you're taking
off your shirt i was like what i was
shocked by that you can't share your
nipple as a guy
but i think what i read is that it's
based on the context so that's why
they're in a pool like you can be oh
really is that what's going on here
is that what it is
i mean that's what they say i don't know
how true
it actually is well anyway twitch isn't
doing anything and the apparently these
girls are just dominating twitch now
this the title of this stream i'm
showing it or we can't well it's they're
just in a bathing suit i don't think
there's anything wrong with that and i
and i just did so hopefully that's okay
um this one's called victoria's secret
bikini try on jacuzzi stream
1080p rank one just chatting just
chatting
let's take a look
like victoria's secret is shaking up the
gate it looks fun out there though like
she's outside she's in the hot tub she's
in the backyard i want to do a jacuzzi
stream
i can't believe this whole situation is
so absurd
you guys crack me up sometimes
i just imagine
she's having so much fun back there with
her boys
you guys are silly oh my god shoes
working for those tips titties
it's like titties
thanks zach
why is that oh zach's being yelled at
what cut to zach
oh he just looks super shocked what was
that zach
nothing nothing
oh okay
everything okay
yeah
you look kind of shocked
no everything's fine okay sorry well
it's cool
oh no someone said
i bet they pee in the hot tub for only
fans
oh dude these girls are do these girls
also have only fans too like is that
something
well i don't know but imagine if they
pee during their stream
let's go dude
can you pee in a kitty tub i mean i
believe the answer is yes to the only
fans question by the way okay so there
you go i mean these these girls are
entrepreneurs i mean not not across the
board but look but i know i got to tell
you i really don't have
i know
you guys are not going to like a lot of
you guys i have no problem with this
i really don't care why do i care oh
guess people say oh it's inconsistent
but like
these girls are entrepreneurs dude they
got only fans they're on twitch i mean
[ __ ] hustle girl get on that banana
you know what i'm saying
for twitch
right
but i feel like the the anger is
misplaced a lot of times why if you
can't show a nipple
that's crazy i can show nips on youtube
whoa
careful
i'm just saying
another reason why youtube is superior
they updated their guidelines in august
i'm sorry what to be more clear
what is it
um well if you're a girl uh we ask that
you cover your nipples we do not permit
exposed underbust cleavage is
unrestricted as long as these coverage
requirements are met
no underbust that that would be the
under titty so
i like i mean i don't know what they
mean that under titty can be pretty hot
you know what i mean
so no under titty
right and then what about the guys
i'm reading up on it now i'm not saying
specifically to guys
people like seaman
well anyway i feel like people are
misplacing their
anger towards these girls and not
towards like okay twitch whatever i
don't know though
you know
but thank you reality well yeah i mean
this is awesome
i mean i have no problem with the girls
who do it
is she really laughing wait what was
that okay she's fake left i was like oh
thank you
i'm confused by this
well okay
okay
well
i mean
this oh here there's here she is in like
literally just a different color bikini
though so
you probably shouldn't ask me how to not
be awkward have any other questions
though i'm down to answer
yep
i'd like to talk to one of these gamers
that are angry about this maybe we can
have someone call in because i feel like
i'm not i just don't know why people are
so angry they say i feel like they say
uh
it's you know the inconsistency but i
feel like that's
they're veiling their anger which is
just at these girls they're jealous
they're jealous that these girls are
racking it up they're at the top of
twitch you know what i'm saying and
they're making a ton of money and these
guys are trying hard to play video games
and like get attention and build a
stream which i get it's tough you know
what i'm saying and life isn't always
fair but i think ultimately they're just
jealous that these girls are crushing it
on twitch i really do
that is it i mean much of the discourse
is about how these channels are being
pushed in the recommended section and a
lot of dudes are upset about it
are they being pushed in the
recommendation section or there's a lot
of people that just want to watch it i
think that there is some truth to that
but but that really it well
it's two sides of the same coin it's
being pushed because people want to
watch it i mean we know how these
algorithms work yeah the algorithm isn't
just putting it up right they know what
people are
people you see titties you click it's
[ __ ] simple math bro
i mean let's face it
i have to just say that it does look
really silly
oh hey i'm not i'm not judging the
merits of it i wouldn't watch it
you know what i'm saying and it's just
funny to me that this is a thing but
are you in your heart today
i don't know i'm not judging the merits
of it i think it's totally [ __ ]
stupid and the fact that there's
actually i mean
clear it's like a e girlfriend thing
because it's like it's just it's just a
cam girl situation
you know
um it's really a sad sight to get
involved in this [ __ ]
where's your daddy oh this one's called
nip slip i didn't see yeah
so
no i already watched it
her titties are fastly secure i'm down
to answer
yep
blame the [ __ ] blame the dudes i mean
blame the people watching it you know
for sure if they're like yo they're
watching the titties and the titty girl
in the jacuzzi instead of me it's like
well step your [ __ ] up bro you got it
you got to compete with titties now
you know what i'm saying that's a tough
competition for anybody yeah people are
mad at these streamers because there are
other cam websites but the gag is
there aren't any websites that have half
as much traffic as twitch that sounds to
me like they found a good a market
opportunity i mean yeah
you know if to if to here i'm i'm open i
want to read everybody's um here's one
the issue is that streamers have been
permanently banned for accidentally
showing as much skin as this girls show
regularly
right
i would agree if this if something like
that happens then i agree that i would
be upset too
they do need to have a consistency
and so again i think these girls end up
being the scapegoats for a lot of these
problems so it's like
twitch is a completely in my experience
with them um
incompetent and competently run and
managed you know what i'm saying yeah
but i feel like the hate is often
misplaced on these girls who are just
hustling
it's like that comment said it's the
most trafficked live site so it's like
hey bro let's go you know what i'm
saying
here's a here's a comment that ian
shared someone said i tested with a
virtual machine in an incognito browser
while connected to vpn
and had multiple hot tub streamers
recommended immediately upon arriving on
the home page this wasn't based on
previous streams clicked or saved
cookies so tell me miners and others who
don't want non-safe for work content on
the homepage should have to resort to
manually clicking not interested each
and every time why can't they implement
blurring of thumbnails like they do an
art sharing platforms like art station
or restrict those kinds of streamers
elsewhere other than the home page where
literally anyone else could visit before
browsing so again that's the issue for
twitch right like the whole thing is a
twitter issue exactly i mean the girls
they're just doing i mean it's available
to them why shouldn't they do it you
know
if if it's a platform with a lot of
traffic it sounds like they're making a
good decision for themselves exactly you
know what i'm saying and if they're
being promoted then even better for them
it's dude this is entirely twitches yeah
this is twitch [ __ ] up i agree if hey
you know
watching video games is a is a for all
ages past time if my eight-year-old son
was on twitch watching this i'd be like
the [ __ ] you doing you know what i mean
so yeah i agree with you that it
shouldn't just be on the home page and
there should be some kind of um
i guess there's another problem is like
this girl based on if you click this she
has normal streams too where she just
plays video games
or watching stuff
so it's like
i twitch got to figure this [ __ ] out bro
yeah
you know i'm socially awkward though so
i mean definitely if she's in a hot tub
in a thong then they should probably
mark it like
but then you you're it's like if you go
to a beach you're going to see girls in
thongs it's like
it's like there's kind of like this new
world thing going on here where it's
like they have to look at this
objectively and be like this is
something you would see on any public
beach
across the country
right
but um i guess there is like
a certain maturity
maybe they i don't know maybe they need
to have like a
maybe it just shouldn't be on the home
page like right there and there i think
that's a reasonable thing to do yeah but
twitch disagrees they like titties
brings traffic to the stream twitter
like titties yeah i like titties titties
who don't like titties
titties titties it's just that
um
like when you go on only fence you know
you're going to get mature
content
when you're going to which i feel like
everyone thinks they're going to get
gaming i agree content
it's odd
here's a clip of uh
asmin gold i guess because
there's
is this still happening love where the
hot tub girls are all dominating the
front page
yeah i mean when i was setting up twitch
on your laptop because there was no
account logged in or whatever when i
first pulled it up um and we weren't
logged into anything the suggestion
thing was like three of them oh really
because i went there last night i was
like where's the hot tub grows at and i
didn't see any because were you logged
in oh here's a girl in a bikini let's
take a look
i think it's because they are pretty
much dominating the just chatting
section don't watch it oh my goodness
what is she what the hell
nobody's waiting man that's a lot um
hang on she's just wearing like pasties
i don't think she's wearing anything no
she's no she's wearing faces i'm just
gonna take this moment to also say
we're not going to ever
ever
ever so this just talk other streamers
on my stream that is something that like
so this is what's going on right now
i will never let's get out of here let's
go
oh yeah recommended just chatting yeah i
don't know i think owner doesn't need to
figure something out
the minimum twitch sign up is 13. so
okay that's interesting instead you have
to be 13 to make an account on twitch
okay is 13 old enough to see some titty
painting yeah
i mean i'd be rubbing one out like
constantly that'd be a problem if i was
on twitch at a 13 year old i'd be like
ooh uh hassan
uh here's a girl painting or tits i'm
like
back to the song
there's a whole ecosystem you know what
it is it's a whole full-service
ecosystem they keep them there because
these kids they're 13 years old they're
watching video games and then when
you're 13 you got to beat one out like
every 10 minutes so then you leave
twitch to go to like pornhub but now
they figured out to have their own
ecosystem you stay on twitch
that's what's going on this is jeff
bezos theories this is high level [ __ ]
so now you got you got [ __ ] you can beat
off you can watch video games you stay
on the website all day instead of
bouncing around
that's what's going on you guys
you know that's what's going on i just
unlocked the [ __ ] true algorithm just
chatting let's see let's see here's
another one uh bad take ethan oh there's
no hate against women
when bikini streams are meta
all gamer girls are flooded with bikini
viewers there is no hate
wait what's my bad thing wait what i
didn't that's not true
i didn't understand my best he's trying
to say that that
people aren't mad at these girls oh they
don't get hate that's objectively not
true no they despise these girls that's
mostly what i see as they not all but
yeah no sorry
you're the one with the bad take reverse
reverse card dan
thank you dan you're a good man dan
no it's look because i was digging into
this yesterday and uh
yeah i mean these girls get a lot of
hate
yeah
so here's another one let's click this
a tiny little tubby
500 euros
this is just a bikini
this is totally fine
if you're from the us you can get it for
a much cheaper i mean it's kind of funny
that they're just hanging out why yeah
how does it feel on a way to be sitting
in this water you see your kits again
maybe
all they had was a donut
yeah let me see your tits again real
fast let me see your ass
hold on hold on i hope this doesn't make
sense hold on hold on hold on don't show
fit
oh you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you just
filled feet
you just you know you really cut away i
don't i don't think we got it
so i see two bikini streamers here in
the top of just chatting
but um
i think i oh here's the third one let's
see empty empty hot tub oh these are
just cats oh
now here's this oh this is my kind of
stream look at that twitch is going to
do something about these cats
people are just watching cats sleeping
there's [ __ ] streams all over twitter
we're making too much money it's a [ __ ]
stream exactly
why is the music still playing oh it's
opens
minimize so um so i only see two and
they're not at the top so that's not
that bad is it
yeah it might be more of an evening
thing though
mm-hmm right before time of day yeah
exactly
i don't know i think i unlocked the
truth
just i don't know doesn't bother me that
much i think twitch is incompetent i've
always said yeah i think that's the root
of the problem you know i can never tell
this story enough times about how twitch
[ __ ] us when our partnership ended
with them and i went back to youtube
they got so mad they killed they said
i'm canceling they canceled our
partnership
so if i ever wanted to come back and
stream on twitch they took rid of my my
sub button
okay
here's the best part out and they didn't
tell me there was no discussion they're
just like [ __ ] you you're not partnered
anymore and then a month later i was
like you guys still owe me money and
they go can you sign up for the partner
program so we can pay you
and i will never get over that because
it's just they they dropped me
from a
purely
like spite yeah out of spite i was like
this company operating from spite yeah
it was so uncalled for it's not like we
did anything unprofessional and we
parted ways amicably they couldn't offer
the deal they were offering sucked and
so i didn't take it yeah but also
prior to the deal we used to stream
sometimes when we felt like it of course
i had the sub button before i not find
it that they just took it it's like okay
we won't even stream there anymore like
weirdos
yeah but then they're like oh you need
to come back and sign up so i can pay
you and i was like i'm not [ __ ] doing
that you guys need to pay me i didn't i
didn't leave the partner program
and so i
i basically just fought with them for
like a month until they just sent a
[ __ ] check
you guys want to just i'll just restream
this yes
here let me mute it nice here i'll just
full i mean yeah little kittens oh
they're kittens oh are they feeding yeah
oh my goodness they got the mama cat
there i'm here live that's not i'm not a
cat
that looks like a cat
this is this is quality content oh you
got any bits we can tip
i don't yeah i don't think so they are
so cute and beautiful i wish i could get
a couch i told you you gotta get that
cat i can't because they'll get out and
die and i just can't deal with that
that would that would suck yeah i can't
we can't like we would have to be really
paranoid about the door right like you
have to always be closed
because the door is always open because
the dog's always coming going and we
hang out outside all the time in
theodore exactly
and there's coyotes look how the kitties
on the he's just sitting on the mommy
oh i'm stroking [ __ ] down here
he's
[Music]
theodore loves cats too cute
our uh
our uh
how would you say how would you call
abby
nanny
yeah
what is it she fosters cats and she
brings cats to our house all the time
and theodore loves them and shredder too
shredder loves the kitty cats
really shredder shredder loves the cats
i would have totally expected him to
like flip out no he always wants to say
hi and he's so curious he wants to smell
oh it all and though and then straight
up we get so obsessed like he can't
that's so cute he scares the little
kitties because they swipe at him
because they're scared because he's just
wanting to smell and say hi and stuff
yeah shredder would love a kitty friend
oh
yeah it's kind of i really want a kid
we can't it's going to get out and die
it'll just be [ __ ] up
like there's no way that cat doesn't get
out like in a week with theodore
well i mean you might be overest like
cats can get away from coyotes like i
had outdoor cats when i lived in an area
with lots of coyotes and and they did
not get murdered by the coyotes not
saying it can't happen but like they're
gonna well are they gonna get a small
dog are we all dogs like shredder are a
lot more vulnerable no but they're gonna
exit the yard the yard is like
relatively safe when we're always out
there right right right that's true but
cats can
they climb trees and stuff like they can
get away um
i just i assume that uh
the cat will just get out i understand
your concern though because there's
definitely a lot of coyotes around and
they run away right they don't like come
back necessarily uh no they do cats
cats have like a crazy sense of
direction yeah buddy if they're neutered
they stay in a
fairly small radius
if they know where their food is and
yeah
they're all about food so i get your
concern though
i want one but i just i don't i i don't
want to be irresponsible cat owner
knowing that it's going to be in danger
and it's hard because
our nani fosters all these cute kittens
so like every month there's like a
really new cute kitten coming by
and then i i don't want to bond with it
because i know
[Music]
every time i'm like maybe we'll keep
this one
yeah
anyway here's asmin gold uh showing how
many titty streamers there are uh
categories just chatting
juan oh yeah
yep
so i see like one two three
four
five
yeah i didn't see that i guess it's a
evening thing yep
that's about right
i feel like wouldn't you turn into
wouldn't you like [ __ ] shrivel up
like a prune if you're sitting a hot tub
all day um
just chatting
hey they suffer for the content bro
what happens is someone's sitting in a
chair 15 hours a day you know i mean
not much better
okay i mean hey i mean what am i missing
am i missing something about this
controversy
does anyone want to call in
oh love correct he says he's not mad
about it love what was his take you said
he made a 10 minute video about
it i don't remember his full take
but uh
he's like a pretty well respected guy on
twitch and his
his takes are
uh pretty calm and
his he thinks twitch or his issue is
that twitch is not very consistent with
the band yeah that's it i think right
he's focusing actually yeah most people
are probably just mad at twitch for
inconsistencies right and these people
that are the loudest are the like
uh the typical twitch chatters that are
just mad at girls for being girls yeah
uh and they're they're the loudest i
think right that's my theory but
according to um
oh this is the girl we're just looking
at i think she's
a warmth a warmth she's one of the
bigger streamers on twitch just amaranth
amaranth oh this is amaranth in case you
guys are curious her
she's made some comments on it
is she live let's see what she's up to
oh she's streaming stream she's sleeping
stream what the [ __ ] is this now this is
weird whoa
okay forget the hot tub yeah we've got 7
500 people watching this girl sleep
did you say sleeping stream
wait
wait did you say sleeping stream so
casually like is this a meta
well yeah i guess and she just does it
regularly
yeah she ha her shot is really weird if
you forget it
oh it's like this hyper
parasocial relationships
yeah yeah that's a big part of it and i
think that's part of it too is people
find that really
cringe and so they hate
the streamers because of their fan base
it's so annoying yeah
um guys this is a billion times weirder
than the hot tub i fully agree with on
that yeah wait let me turn the
yo what the hell
so she's getting paid to sleep i mean
that's the pit that's like the
definition of crushing it
how many viewers
seven thousand five hundred pretty good
pretty damn good good uh that's right
i mean those are good numbers for anyone
yeah yeah even live
that's like a top channel yeah
holy [ __ ]
is there some kind of mechanism to wake
them up with like a big donation or
something love
um there usually is but i don't think
she has it
she just wants to [ __ ] sleep and make
some money passively would you be down
to set up a sleeping live stream i mean
i feel like didn't people do it as like
a one-time challenge like
yeah there's this one guy that was he
didn't stop streaming for like yeah
but he was streaming herself sleeping
and stuff
but this is just uh
this is just life for her
her average viewers are eleven thousand
so she's not even
wow
you think the reason you would want to
watch it
obsession you're in love with her yeah
i was going to ask love do you think any
of our audience has a chance with her
69. of course
yeah of course they didn't donate enough
if you donate enough i know that i heard
you never missed the stream i could be
off base here but i i thought i had
heard about her that she's um that she's
married
oh
you guys don't have a chance with her
she's married they don't seem to care
well maybe her marriage isn't
perfect you know have we ever thought
about that she's sleeping by herself
she's married she sleeps by herself for
the stream what's going on here
does she ever sleep with her husband
love
something tells me the husband doesn't
make too many appearances on her uh live
stream
and she kept it you can't kill you can't
kill that illusion yeah exactly so this
has a term like parasocial
parasocial relationship is just a
concept where psychological
you uh
yeah you find yourself uh thinking that
you're actually friends with the
internet personalities that you follow
closely because of
and it's become a bigger and bigger
thing uh in the last you know decade or
two because of
you know social media but in particular
live streaming you know these people are
live all day every day and
they have these fan bases that hang out
with them and they they you know form
management do i
whatever i got to say just keep watching
don't leave me
please um i think i have a parasocial
relationship with ela
i think it's a little more than bear
i'm convinced that she's in love with me
sleep streams are super common well show
me another sleep stream because this now
why are people talking about hot tubs
i'm [ __ ] fascinated by the sleep
streams bro
that's way weirder someone find me a
sleep stream here she is doing yoga you
want to watch this
i can't believe she's married you guys
how
oh
yoga streams
i mean she streams everything though it
seems like yeah am i going to judge her
so he's in a hot tub she's doing yoga
she's streaming her whole damn life
probably she all makes sense i mean she
probably streams poop come never bought
for christ's sake
i mean what's the limit
maybe against terms of service on twitch
i just find it funny i agree with love
that this is
uh you know i think most people up in
arms about this it is more about the
twitch policies
what'd you find now so booba.tv oh is
that what they call boobs booba
so now they have here's a collection of
all not
nsfw streams on twitch right now she's
number one
her sleeping is number one
we saw her
oh that's that's gotta be heartbreaking
for these other girls you're literally
losing out
to a girl
here's a girl on a beach let's check
this out
an ad really okay you okay that block
doesn't work on twitch they
figured it out
just playing
for yourself that's pretty awesome
where's youtube at on that
yeah it's i'm surprised they haven't
i'm assuming the reason youtube doesn't
care about adblock is because they don't
even have enough ads to serve all the
traffic
you know what i mean there's enough
people not using adblock that they're
able to serve every ad that they sell
right
so they're like ah [ __ ] it could be this
commercial is so long oh my god there's
no like skip
quickbook to people watching twitch for
real people watching tuition and quick
[ __ ]
maybe not the best target they got it
they got it oh did you just [ __ ] oh
you could you hit pause
i can't pause it what kind of [ __ ] is
this you got another ad
oh dude i want to pull up that ear
looking [ __ ] what were you looking at
um i don't know people said to look at
another girl oh yeah i want to look at
that then equality
they need quickbooks to manage their
twitch donations
oh my god this is killing me it's still
going jesus all right can i just look at
some some titties on the beach there we
go
so this girl's on the beach i mean
that's kind of cool she's on a little
adventure
looks nice
it looks beautiful this girl said
brianna go ahead when we were long
distance
uh my husband and i would sleep on video
call it just feels cozy to have someone
sleep with like oh i get that like
there's a connection i'm guessing these
sleep streams emulate that so you think
they're sleeping with her oh dude i'm
sorry but that makes me uncomfortable
like i get it you're intimate an
intimate relationship with your spouse i
get sleeping with the stream i mean
that's nice right but like i mean this
is someone on twitch sleeping
you're a weirdo bro
i mean
okay
um this is the girl painting our titties
we saw that this girl's on a boat with
the smallest bikini i've ever seen
and another person said i love sleep
streams i watch someone tick talk it's
super calming and it helps me sleep
really yeah would you guys watch me s
would you guys watch me sleep
pay-per-view i sleep naked
[Laughter]
so
okay so i guess there's there's
something for everybody eh oh here's a
girl licking the this is what uh this
shit's so wild watch this
this is live right now she's just
licking a microphone
oh
oh my goodness
so this is this is
yeah
this is awesome
imagine explaining this to your mom
i mean at least asmr is becoming a
little more
but do you know about this thing it's a
so the mic is a ear it looks like an ear
she's licking the ear
what is she saying i can't hear her
she's so tough
oh god
so is this so are we considering this
sexual or no
i think we've had this one
yeah
in regards to asmr it is and it isn't
yeah it's not but we lean more towards
not yeah well in this case though i mean
not asmr in general but this is why is
there more
looking in here
less sexual than the than the jacuzzi
streams
here can i do something for you guys
i guess god stop doing it i hate it
people hate it okay i hate it i have
these headphones on
so here so it doesn't look that bad i
just got to say it doesn't look that bad
look at the um gif of the website
from like hebrew because
bubba is a doll
i think it's just them
i honestly i don't know goofy baby talk
for boobs i think
titties titties
oh bring them bring them bring them
that's exciting all right i will uh also
this girl wait let me let me quote so
this girl uh
amber amaranth the girl who's sleeping
right now
yeah she says she believes it's good for
the platform her argument is that data
indicates that some of the viewers stick
around for gaming and other that's what
i'm saying they game and then they jerk
off and they go back to the gaming it's
good because if you go to their cycle
overview i'm telling you they're missing
the point these gamers are missing the
point because if they go to pornhub and
jerk off they're probably not going to
come back to twitch yeah it's good for
them because now they're gonna go watch
amarath bust one out and come back and
continue watching your dumbass play
[ __ ] overwatch
i'm saying y'all gotta this is a
symbiotic relationship this is like on
the force when the mushrooms feed the
trees and
you don't go oh oh the mushrooms are
taking my nutrients no they're helping
you grow right
she says i can play games or just talk
to my chat sitting on my desk for 10 000
people
i imagine internally twitch is seeing a
huge surge influx of people coming from
off platform people who are likely
reoccurring users it's hard to buy
marketing like that the meta is
generating a lot of uh mind share what
muncher and it piques people's curiosity
i think the narrative is that it takes
viewers away from other creators is
false and that the girls engage in hot
tubbing are doing that
yeah yeoman's work of growing the whole
part viewership pie i think she's right
actually
huh
oh he just uploaded a third part his uh
documentary can someone watch it and see
if it's interesting or should i just
pull it up i'm watching it right now so
just pirate it
hey we can tell you
she also says um that because of this
harassment has gone way up so much
attention has been brought up to hot
stream uh hot tub streamers harassment
has gone way up
oh this is someone named fire dance
people jump on cancer culture trends and
although these types of streams are fun
and not breaking any rules some viewers
and other streamers are unable to simply
scroll past without voicing their
opinion some viewers have gotten very
toxic in the last weeks
i totally agree that i mean i totally
believe that yeah amaranth says that
she's ever uh she's says that she's even
seen a lot more conservative
uh female broadcasters get undue hate or
sexual harassment regardless of what
they do however she does not believe
that this perception of twitch mods
being more lenient on women holds weight
interesting she said i don't think girls
are on balance treated better than guy
streamers with regards to moderation
this is a very unpopular opinion but i
think a lot of the perceived asymmetry
is caused by twitch not publicizing the
reasons why they take action against
streamers social media loves opening up
top opini wow this girl's like pretty
smart opining busting out the good words
and [ __ ] what does that mean
uh sharing singing yeah social media
loves opining about topics
when there is imperfect information even
when we hypothetically concede that
female streamers have more leniency i
always find it rather amusing that
people argue so hard for twitch to be
more strict with regards to its terms
rather than less that's a good point i
yeah that's
spot on and that was what was driving me
nuts about is like this whole like
hyping all these guys that are hyping
themselves up about going after them and
like trying to get them banned it's like
isn't
isn't the whole problem that they're
that they're too harsh on the bands and
you can get banned for like
great they're working against their own
interests absolutely because it's
they're just bitter and jealous
if two people are perceived to break the
same rule one receives a lesser sentence
there's so much more buzz around making
sure the person with the shorter
suspension gets banned longer twitch is
already much more strict than say
youtube with regards to content
moderation i think that in cases where
there seems to be ambiguity or
inequality around terms of service
enforcement it would be far more
constructive if the community rallied
behind the more forbearing enforcement
but i guess that's not how the internet
works very insightful comment by
amaranth
it's a good nuanced take
also they still never said why they
banned for example
the doc insane
yeah
all right we want to bring that caller
in
uh
yeah
yeah
uh so he is a pro he's anti hot tub what
what's our take here
uh i i think that he's pretty upset from
from what i could gather when we were
talking to him before the show
he seemed pretty heated oh is this ben
yeah oh ben shapiro he's okay so ben
shapiro is here
yeah
yeah i thought it was a real car but i
mean it is a real car it's a real band
yeah it's ben
okay well let's hear let's hear what ben
has to say about the whole situation i'm
sure
no he's gonna have a good take i'm
pretty sure he always does wait hold on
one sec ian do you see this here what's
going on here
you see what i'm highlighting
so
um
dan do you see what i'm highlighting
nope i'm dealing with the call
okay well um
ben is
ben is uh let's just bring him on
okay uh just let him in
one second
ben are you uh are you there
uh yes i am
thank you for calling in again
i appreciate your insights although i
may not always agree with you but i i
think the dialogue is important you know
a meeting of great minds
absolutely yes i'm very excited to be on
here again
so ben what is your thoughts on the hot
tub situation on twitch
well i'm very glad you gave me the
chance to chime in ethan because frankly
it's appalling to see these ladies
promote such terrible bathing habits
first off some parts of this
yeah i mean i mean have you have you
seen these i mean
first off like i said some parts of that
skin known as glabrous skin they have a
highly reactive response to h2o this
skin which occupies spaces on a various
phalanges can become wrinkled like a
prune f cup california raisin in at
least 320 seconds
you're just concerned about pruning huh
that's the amazing
that's why i never spend
more than 20 milliseconds at a time in
water
20 milliseconds
as long as how else do you think i keep
this astro guide so deal complexion of
mine
so yeah okay
interesting so your problem with the
twitch streamers is less so the
sexuality and more the impractical
bathing that you see
well well there are two parts of it yes
i mean the impractical bathing is
astonishing um but and on that i mean
there should be nothing you know there
should be nothing sexual about breasts
anyway i mean that's kind of my problem
with it any breasted for feeding little
baby benny not to be ogled after 2000
boys hopped up on g fuel and 1.7 kd
ratio it is absolutely ridiculous
so you're you resent
you resent the very notion of breasts
being sexual at all they're pre they're
they're they're only for reproductive
purposes and feeding baby are you
talking about yourself by the way little
betty benny is that you
well yeah and i mean my children right
and i guess
yes i went through the same process as
well it's a reproductive process like
you mentioned that's what it's that's
what they're there for so you're not you
don't find breasts attractive
at me particularly no not in particular
right now no right okay
well that makes sense so it's like why
are you guys even looking at these it's
like
for reproductive burst business only so
what do you think twitch should do do
you think switch needs to do anything
about this
i i i think so i mean you know a lot of
this stuff is it's very unsettling and
me personally i think it's very unfair
because
i don't know if you've heard but i have
been banned on twitch before so you know
i would love to stream my little ps4
nipples to the world but because i'm a
man it is suddenly not high viewer
showcase which is completely unfair and
a double standard amount everywhere
okay wow i didn't know that ben shapiro
you what were you banned on twitch for
well it i want to get into it but i may
or may not have had a heated moment on
the pub g bridge that's awesome oh
ben shapiro you had a heated gamer
moment
i i did it's not my proudest moment
but it still does not defeat the point
that i just made about the double
standard
about men
wow
so ben shapiro said a gamer word and was
banned from twitch it sounds to me like
you're just bitterly jealous that these
girls are able to just show some titty
and get lots of views
i mean i i mean i just agree because
there's a lot of i mean there's more
than just you know the sexual portion of
it that is driving me insane i mean i i
also want to i'm watching these they're
watching these these streams and i want
to know if there's any sort of
filtration system for the large standing
water i mean what sort of care is going
on here i can just imagine the level of
havoc that is wreaking on their wall
paint right i mean they're talking about
the molding and moisture molding this is
and there's all sorts of negative things
on here right well that is a that is a
good observation i hadn't thought about
that
right i mean you're going to wet you're
going to end up with a wet ass keyword
and the p stands for paint is what it
stands for oh no no no no no
all right ben listen as always i thank
you for your amazing insights
yeah
um i didn't think i we got to let make
sure these girls know about the the
danger of mold and water filtration yeah
yeah those are really good observations
thank you very much your intellect is uh
your intellect is unmatched right right
yeah i am glad that i was able to you're
giving me a platform to point this out
thank you thank you of course always
it's my pleasure thank you ben
all right thank you very much everyone
at h3 thank you take care ben ben
shapiro
no more heated gamer moments ben shapiro
ladies and gentlemen
wet ass p word always with really good
insights honestly
i i understand why they say he's so
smart
you know
didn't know about the
the bridge incident that that was him he
had a heated gamer moment on that rig
you hate to see it
oh you guys wanted to see some other
crazy [ __ ] i mean did i miss anything i
think i got it the whole bottom you know
i don't know if there's anything else to
say about the whole hot tub phenomenon
can we secretly cut to baby
baby what are you doing what are you
doing are you gaming no he's doing it no
he's watching he's watching the jeff
video
anything interesting going on there
uh yeah but i think maybe better for
frenemies in my humble opinion
you want to give us some like bullet
points
um so i'm halfway in but it's about
jeff's second surgery and david's in it
a lot more this time oh and uh yeah
is it a redemption david arc
two degrees so far yeah it's
he wants david to go skydiving with him
to make up for it
to put him in an uncomfortable position
um
should probably [ __ ] hit his eye with
a tractor also easy he keeps making
jokes about it he keeps like showing him
ice cream scoopers and
making jokes about taking out david's
eye okay thanks for the update
no problem oh here's a video of mia
khalifa picking up dog [ __ ] with her
mask and then putting the mask on now
there's a whole big debate in our um
there's a big debate back here about if
this is real or fake but anyway here's
the video then we can uh debate it so
it's me khalifa
picks up a dog turd
with their mask
throws it out
all right
puts the mask back on
wait so
just strangers
so apparently this guy so this is part
of the intrigue is that the guy who
posted it is some famous
dj or some [ __ ] what's the story
anyone
ian you know
he's a musician producer yeah but he's
got these like funny tick tock videos or
quote unquote funny that's got to be
fake
so
so here's where i don't understand
is that she
has like i don't see what this does for
her right and also she never said it was
fake she responded to the clip by saying
like why is i'm following the law
and i'm not leaving my dog poop on the
ground like it's like why are you guys
mad at me that was her comment
[Laughter]
holy
so
i'm with you ethan i i'm a little
baffled by it because
you know i can maybe accept that it's
fake but but to what end like what right
because she just looks like a lunatic
yeah and then this one was a banger
video why would you fake that
friends like her and the guy
good question i don't know that answer
mia commented she was just following the
law now here's my pro real observation
you know you don't see the dog pooping
but what you do see
as the video is about to restart
is the dog wiping his feet on the grass
that's what do you think the little kick
thing yeah i mean that's a clear so she
turned it inside out and she moves on
now that's a clear indication that dog
just pooped now hold on let's watch
again from the beginning
here you notice the dog is wiping his
feet right right he's doing the thing
right
so
love you have something prepared you
have evidence that you think it's faked
yes uh i
analyzed the video okay closer dick in
hand
not in hand
i had to focus full focus
and
this is what i found okay let's see it
okay love is coming with the receipts
here
before
and after
what am i looking at love so on the left
side before the poop is on the ground
right there
the poop is still on the ground
afterwards as you can see in the second
picture
hold on now let me watch it again now
i swear she picked it up
you need so many
more i can't zoom in anymore but i could
see the poop it's right here in the
shadow there it is
i think it's she picked me up
something else
it does there's still a little log there
i think
now
let me help you watch this again
hang on
okay one more time
okay there's a possibility she has
something in her left hand
okay so right here's the poop
um
i think she's picked you can see it in
there you can see the poop in the mask
no there is something in the mask but he
thinks it's not full
why wouldn't she put pick all the poop
up
if if you're if you're taking the poop
up you're taking all the poop otherwise
there would be no appointment i don't
know if this is com i don't know if this
is fully compelling i'm well i'm
intrigued by his argument i gotta say
well there could possibly have been it's
like a hand
what's this it could also be
been a sleight of hand if you look at
her left hand when she's picking up
right before she's picking it up
you could have placed something in the
mask right there
if you look closely so you think it's a
sleight of hand
i think so yes
to what end though exactly what is the
goal here
views
but how does it benefit her
all the attention is good attention i'm
not right okay so we got the poop here's
the poop okay so she's picked she's
picking something up we agree on this
possibly she could have put something
already in because she's not even
willing to go that far yeah why would
she leave it on the ground though why
would she leave that big loophole in the
video
i wanted some mistake maybe
i thought you couldn't tell
i mean i think there's just a shadow
there or something there but she
definitely picked something up
um i don't know
compare the pictures
i mean yeah no i i here's the pictures
once again
i'm gonna pull i'm gonna pull the
audience
i already did oh nice i mean listen if
you have to ask me then
i do think it's probably fake based on
the setup and everything but
i know i don't want to be known as the
guy who [ __ ]
picks up a mask and with dog [ __ ] in
and puts it back on his face you know
also it just happens to be like this
world famous dj is just sitting there
filming
a video of mia khalifa like right at
that moment with perfect framing
yeah that's pretty sketchy
i still just don't get the objective
there though that's what
it's the only thing throwing me off but
um
i'm looking at the straw poll right now
and uh it's overwhelmingly uh the fakes
are uh winning it
yeah
unfortunately i do think it's fake but
i want to believe it's real
i just don't get it i mean he seems to
benefit the most and she what she's a
poop now she's just known as miller yeah
she's the poop face
she's a poop
smeller she's a poop smelling woman
it's an epic troll and she's the master
troll right now
your mask is making me uncomfortable
right especially when there's poop on it
okay
yeah it's probably fake
well i just find it odd too that like
she's like what's the problem you know
what i mean where did she say that
i like in what way i think it was a
response on twitter or something um
now the race tweet
you guys you guys know how i feel about
chiropractors right watch this [ __ ]
first time
you see this
yep you saw that right
you know you've
oh dude leave this poor guy alone oh
yeah this is the weirdest [ __ ]
did you taste it
yeah
i could literally taste my crack that
sounds fun yeah i want to say [ __ ] in my
mouth
it doesn't even look good
chiropractors are the biggest scammers
bro
stop it
stop
either how's your back feeling stop you
want to get some you want to get train
tracks laid in your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
paul bunyan i have another sledgehammer
boom
psycho psycho
what's the science behind that i'd like
to know
there's a lot of chakra up there i'm
gonna unblock with this metal pipe
how long we've been going down a little
over two hours
we have a loft here this is kind of an
interesting
little segment we've got here
um
let's do this oh we have a tearless
generator all ready to go
yeah
i'm stepping up stepping up the game
oh wow more photoshop both so how does
this work
you can just drag and drop those little
uh oh for real yeah oh that's so cool
how did you do that
i whipped up a little program now okay
so it's not an existing website so we
have as you guys know a lot of laughs
and our drops
vin diesel ricegum wendy williams tucker
joker eli myself dan
et cetera et cetera and so on so we're
thinking to do a laugh tier list here
today
based on the drop
but before that i gotta pee ela you take
the shell
um can you also bring water with you
water i'm going right here
from the sink
okay you want water
squeezing my dick because that's water
you have to be that bad
okay i have to pee so bad what do we do
now i'm gonna read chat
um when does the tf corduroy jacket
comes out um next month and i'm
so excited about that one
so excited
um
why is david's sexuality important what
were you guys talking about here
in jeff's new video
um in jeff's new video jeff told him
like before david jumped out of the
plane he goes
is there anything you want to ask me
before i jump and jeff said are you gay
and
david said yes i like boys before he
jumped out and jeff's like i still don't
know if he was kidding or not though
i'm guessing that's what they're
referring to i miss the mark with that
one
oh god
oh we can look at the picture of kirby
the you guys want to see a picture of
kirby the dog we got it
yes we have it oh let's [ __ ] go
let's see this little angel oh wait so
it'll be on ethan's laptop yeah
i have to reach over there
where do you send it
uh in discord yes okay
uh
all right
in the meantime how the [ __ ] do i join
discord linked my account but now i'm
just staring at the discord home
touching myself okay you've got to um go
into the connections tab in your
settings and uh
connect
your youtube to your discord account and
then you should be able to join there's
kirby
what a little crown
look at that cute
dogs are the best
when is the frenemies merch
i believe
that it's gonna officially come out in
june
all right guys
how's everybody oh this is kirby yeah
it's kirby we got kirby oh he's got a
crown and i know what a king and a cake
love me some kirby
[Laughter]
i love this guy
yeah oh is he wearing a teddy fresh one
breaker
oh it looks good oh yeah
i know teddy fresh when i see
it good legend
he looks like he's got his girl on zoom
or something too
oh
love your dog bro that's a great very
good
i love you yeah love your ass bro keep
slamming
legend [ __ ] bro
good vibes all right let's do some let's
do some uh laugh to your list shall we
we shall
all right
let's start
so how are we determining this just the
quality i mean is this some kind that's
what i was about to ask like what's the
parameter votes you know what i'm saying
like i feel like this is just going to
be very arbitrary how infectious it is
yeah what brings the most joy it's
laughs which laughter is most
interesting joy is so but so like rice
gum is going to be like f-tier right
even though i'd like it as a drop i
don't know though because i
because i get very happy when i hear
that one
yeah exactly so so how do we just like
uh feelings of joy is that what we're
writing yeah maybe like infectiousness
contagiousness um usability should that
be like how many times have we lost the
sound right yeah
how come there's no f here by the way
only d
it's the website we were using
oh they limited it to diana
jeez i don't know how to reclassify
these
let's just start and then think about it
i guess
all right
just follow your gut let's start with
the diesel father god vin diesel
vin diesel's up first
i mean
i know it's early and it might seem
early to
hold on
yeah play it
so dude
how is that not s i feel like they're
all gonna be s
no no no no
we're just starting with one of them
now slow it down
it's got such
it's
slow it down more sounds like a truck
now speed it up
now let me hear it original
oh we have the uh janice okay this is
great so we can watch the moment
when this laugh was created maybe for
more content people saying cd to this
are you kidding me what are you telling
me what are you doing
total disconnect here it is here's the
last
god she's so beautiful
am i right or wrong look at her
how am i supposed to do this interview
look at this woman tell me your story
she's so beautiful
man
i don't know why but he looks so
unattractive here he looks like such a
goon and that's a sheriff
he just looks like such a goon bro
i can't
so tom hanks
i found out that you are a nerd like me
you love the jews and dragons i'm
anything like you because i love you
i'm anything like it because i love you
guys really where's the laughs she is
you guys think it's a joke how am i
supposed to sit over here when i'm
looking at such beauty bro you gotta
chill come on you're ruining this
i'm in love
i'm in love with the interview
okay after a really bad joke too
that was some
interview
i never heard it sound like that how you
guys are not going to say an s
[Music]
i'm sorry i know it's against the cur
oh the overwhelming majority are voting
b but i wouldn't say overwhelming
it's uh well s is not people are not
feeling the ass we got like b c a
let me call pretty let me put it up it's
like maybe we're
sounds like
do i need to consider the these i mean s
is not even close maybe give it an a
i think a would be okay between the
audience who we will respect and
ourselves we're gonna place finn at an a
yeah all right i think that's important
to distinguish between the interview and
the laugh like the best moments are what
he says in the interview
i think they'll laugh on its own i mean
my gut instinct was boom s but okay i'll
respect the people the wish of the
people and zach has really made that
laugh transcend it's become just like
part of his arm yeah i mean exactly yeah
anytime there's anything remotely horny
going on that that laugh gets busted out
all right let's bring out rice gum now
and of course the genesis of the laugh
is him making fun of ela
which is like the biggest uh
pretty much the biggest l of all time
goes to ricegum for this video
and this was during a time when people
didn't even really like me and his video
still got like 80 dislikes
yeah everyone defended hilo in this
video even the quartering like i mean
the attack was for the quartering yeah
holy [ __ ] even he's recording's about to
build a shed in your honor hila thank
you
[Laughter]
and go pee in it
i mean the attack was so unwarranted
he's like he's like oh you know what's
the real problem with ethan his wife is
boring
here
yeah
and like youtube is like a dream job and
people would probably want to be in his
shoe so
i'm really trying to think i'm not a
therapist or anything and this is like
towards the end of the video so a lot of
people might not even see this so i'm
just going to say how it is i think i
love the confidence in his video making
where he thinks that people are not even
watching at this five minute mark of his
video of a six minute video
i know people don't watch my videos all
the way in so i'm just gonna say it this
boy is depressed or whatever because his
girl be just so wacky like i'm sorry
someone has to say it but like every
time his girl is in a video bro it's
just crickets soldiers go just walk into
them this is the
by the way if you want to talk about
monotone voices
i can't believe he was actually doing
thought he was doing something with this
so i mean the laugh is great
it makes me feel bad it's a bad feeling
because i don't like
it always makes me giggle every time i
hear it though right yeah it's just so
good right
i don't know for me it's like uh
see i don't know how to rate it i just i
don't know how to rate it because it's
like it's a good oh wait people are
saying s wow wow it's way up there see i
don't understand the logic i kind of get
it i think it's because it's a quick i
don't know right
it's a quick like can you throw it into
anything yeah exactly oh there's no f by
the way uh
hmm well i don't think it's an s i was
going to give it like a i mean see i'm
conflicted because i don't like him but
i like the sound bite
okay let's give it a s you guys agree i
i think we have right
okay
i'm a little confused but i'll keep
pressing forward
wendy williams up next
let's hear it
someone said as a member of the asian
community i seriou i sincerely apologize
for this creature's actions
we certainly don't hold it against you
or yeah i would exactly i don't hold it
against the asian community no of course
not i would never look at it like that
that's
outrageous
wendy williams uh go ahead zack
[Laughter]
wait is that a laugh though
i've i've been i've interpreted it as a
laugh i mean i think okay
let's watch the video
i think she is laughing
but she's like running she makes noises
that i never
heard other human beings make
and also what is she doing with the
q-tip like whoever thought to wipe their
eyes with the cute thing she's trying to
not mess up
i know but like how many like she's a
professional friar
she had it standing by so yeah
um
[Laughter]
slow that one down speed it up give me
different dimensions here
[Music]
and like the wave sounds like a
car struggling to turn over you know
sometimes they hear mysterious sounds in
the ocean
right yeah they're like
the grand yeah
yeah
it sounds like you're trying to yeah
danny right get in the car
how do you do that
yeah i mean it's s obviously right
let's see what the poll says the people
have spoken
so here's wendy straight into the s tier
thank you wendy for your contributions
to humanity
huh okay let's play tucker carlson a new
addition to the show
we watched this recently on the off the
rails episode and he is a full-on
meltdown he's been losing his mind over
pretty much everything and i guess this
would happen when uh uh derek chovin
when he went to jail yeah when he got
the guilty verdict yeah he was
and tucker has a meltdown the scene i i
just think that it was excessive and it
shouldn't happen and what i'd like to do
the guy who did it looks like he's going
to spend the rest of his life in prison
so i'm kind of more worried about the
rest of the country which thanks to
police in action in case you haven't
noticed is like boarded up
so that's more of my concern but i
didn't even understand his point thank
you i don't nope
and then he cuts them off nope nope nope
we're done
so totally joker brain moment from
tucker or as i like to call him tuck the
dick but between the legs carlson
sounds like a squirrel or something
i mean it's it's good
it's i don't know wait hit me with that
pitched up a little bit
yeah yikes
so
i don't know for me i'm in the middle of
the pack maybe
it's kind of i'd give it c
two yeah
that's what the people are saying as
well
that's a solid that's a steven we're all
on the same page
just straight to the back to the
straight face
that's what gets me
psychotic
uh c
sorry
so you know what c stands for his [ __ ]
between his legs oh that was carlson
nope you thought wrong
all right now we have a whole uh
plethora of joker actually no it's only
two
i stand corrected
so we have a we have a standoff of joker
laughs we have chet hanks here
who's in who's really showcasing his
acting chops
everybody's
plans
and i just want to show them how useless
they are
me i don't have a plan i'm like a dog
chasing cars i wouldn't know what to do
if i got it
what the [ __ ] dude that is so great it's
really good i have to say
i'm kind of ready for chet hanks as the
joker
it's soaked compared to jared leto's
laugh
and then play jared letos we don't have
the clip but we have the sun bite
how does anyone take that man seriously
[Laughter]
dude come on jared leto ed got [ __ ] on
chet hanks
jet hugs would be an amazing champion
i'm gonna
as much as i'd like
chets i think it's too fresh it hasn't
really right fully found its place in
our hungry so we have chat and then we
here's the issue with that dan i don't
think we've shown this clip before so
there's really not a lot of context to
it right oh we oh really yeah that was
the first time we ever showed it yeah i
think where you just put it is is
healthy i think i'm gonna say b that's
actually what the vote says too
everyone's on oh so the straw polls okay
so chet hanks straw poll
is a solid b oh there you go yeah yeah
and then if we can get one going for um
jared
that one's definitely better than gender
if it's up to me i mean i like its use
though so that's where i'm completely
see i
my instinct goes
to the top with this one
it's so powerful play the jared laughs
please there's two of them there's two
of them are you talking about the
they're both the package it's a package
deal play them both
and then the other one
[Laughter]
this guy has won an academy award
[Laughter]
all right the people have spoken for
jared he's an ass
oh you know what's really interesting
about jarrah jared
s and sd
yeah it's polarizing it's very
polarizing oh no no it's it's evening
but then 30.
right i think the people have spoken
that jared is s-class i think he's this
one
it's technically the worst one but it's
exactly because of that exactly the best
of the worst
exactly you can i mean you this one is
like
really great like yeah yeah exactly
i just can't get over this guy's an
academy award-winning actor
he's okay i mean not to stick up for
jared leto too much but i've seen him
he's good in movies occasionally
listen i just don't think he's a good
joker why do people
like why did why and then like why is he
gonna go recast him and he put him at
the end of the
did you ever watch schneider cut nah
really after all this [ __ ] you talked
and you wouldn't sit down and watch it
i liked it i don't want to [ __ ] watch
that [ __ ] i liked it
i thought it was good man i enjoyed it
except the end with jared leto which was
[ __ ] horrible it was so stupid
i like it all right
up next is ela cline we know and love
her beautiful uh talented
could you guys find a smaller uh video
this one's great
how small this is what the [ __ ] is this
well this was the origin
it's like this was the post that so this
one
not making an impression
it's a snyder cut it's called letterbox
okay okay all right let's everybody
listen cause it's subtle this one's
great
yeah that was pre-rice gum it's such a
rice gum lock this one's great
i think it's a cute life though if i'm
being honest
it's just natural you're just loving
life
this one's great
i mean for me if it's eva it's s every
time
[Laughter]
i thought that's a good one
it's funny because i thought that it was
originated from me impersonating where
is going oh
how do you feel now that you know it's
not
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know
they sound very similar
funnily enough he was trying to make fun
of you but but the truth is that you
guys have the same you have the same
laugh in that situation
all right
all right we got a poll for ela i mean
it's got to be s come on
am i wrong
am i right on my wrong
i'm right
i'm just even putting her up here
because i know it's it says yeah
congratulations ela ester thank you i'm
in great company there
here it is for the prosthetic prosperity
process prosperity possibility posterity
a huge s wow
overwhelming
hit us with it one more time zach play
us out
[Music]
fair enough uh up next is me
ethan klein your beloved host
that's me
oh jesus
wait have you ever played that um
what was this from the
what was it from oh they got together
when i was on the gatsby
like legit if we called it i'd be sorry
i don't know i
[Laughter]
i feel like we could do it too because
you just pay money for the vip and
they'll let you do whatever you want
people convince me not to do it
there's lots of comments like don't do
that okay
dude imagine did i see it already
i i listen i think it's so funny do that
i get that it's insensitive but it's
like i mean
it's kind of worth the joke to be
insensitive for a day
you know what i mean it doesn't harm
anyone it would ruin disneyland
it totally would ruin the whole park
everybody in the whole park would be
talking about it
the whole park the whole world would
talk about it it goes super viral
[Laughter]
all right i still want to do it
i obviously will abstain from voting for
myself but
well the vote is in the vote is in
that's here
result is oh
thank you very much i feel honored yes
thank you guys wow it's an honor
thank you guys
flattered overwhelmed uh
honestly a little bit speechless here
you guys caught me off guard yes wow
thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you wow peace and love
ethan go into the s tier
what do we what do we got next we got
dan oh dan with the laughs
[Music]
here we go
this was what the hell is it
dan laugh compilation are you serious i
didn't know about this
did you know about this i didn't i knew
about it as of last night when the guys
damn laughing compilation aka your
dearly serotonin oh my god
because i tell him like you're not my
type either nine and a half minutes of
this [ __ ]
he's like a toy it's like oh i got a
middle eastern you know oh my god i'm
fine
i cannot [ __ ] believe you're coming
to rosh hashanah dinner
this is so [ __ ] up
it's kind of weird to watch it online
you're like 22. that's what i said
yeah pull it out because i even showed
him inappropriate age for him he's like
like that's not what you were saying
you were saying under 18.
i feel like they could cut it more or
just like a continuous stream of
laughing i didn't say under 18 there's
somebody put a lot of them said there's
no way let me skip forward
my house currently is beetlejuice the
new house we're getting is going to be
prince of egypt this one's beetlejuice
what's wrong we love a theme you love it
all right there's dan laughing everybody
loves dan's laugh
i feel like the s is getting pretty
crowded well that's what i'm saying
laughter is a beautiful thing i mean and
these are all good sound bites you know
so
there's one more slap is a big part of
the show
yeah i mean here's another s
everyone is saying in the comments too
yeah i mean exactly it's like uh dan is
our laugh track
right if it wasn't for dan laffin y'all
wouldn't even be enjoying this show
probably yeah people like this
[ __ ] is so unfunny and by the
way dan i resent how much you bet you
were like yeah that's right
because i was like if it wasn't for dan
laughing
you guys would think i'm so funny and
dan goes yeah
like i'm sorry dude are you laughing or
not
the best way i can describe dan's laugh
it's like the floor
of the podcast it's always there it's
the floor
baby foundation
my favorite moment since working for you
guys
had to do with zach saying something i
tried so hard to hold my laugh and i
like faintly heard zach dan laughing in
the background i burst it out laughing
zach does crack me up i gotta say
well i'm very special
i am very grateful for dan's laughter
because it makes me feel uh more
confident during the show yeah it really
does it's funny how it just happened
like
i feel like in the old
room set up
it was almost impossible to hear him but
you would still yeah people would
comment you just it was very funny
totally become like
such a cool now we're in the same room
so well i always say comments like when
you guys move to the new office don't
right
so i was like oh i'm getting you know
i'm gonna mic dan
there needs to be like we're trying to
actually figure that in our office how
to
mic the back room so we can hear the
left i don't know we'll figure it out i
remember that
we should just hire someone that sounds
like dan just
impossible
thank you dan for all the laughs
i hear that dude shoots his gym shorts
all the time
so oh there's kind of a funny update
about him which is that
the new episode of impulsive he's like
mike is in here because i didn't invite
him
because he's pissed about when mike
this guy is such a [ __ ] he did it to
lana too which we showed he calls people
or accept calls while he's live and
doesn't tell them
and so logan said something about david
dobrik which obviously didn't want he
wasn't prepared that it was being
broadcasted in his live stream
and uh he got super pissed at mike
rightfully and i guess they're on rocky
terrain and mike is a total [ __ ] he's
lost lana logan's mata
the stream that we saw of all of them
together wasn't that already after the
incident
um i'm talking i don't know what you're
talking about but logan just put out a
new episode okay
that was without him
no he's didn't he say in the episode
that's why he didn't bring him oh here
here's the clip
you might notice that we are not
in a regular set in encino california
rather we are in uh dorado puerto rico
otherwise known as heaven on earth you
might also notice
there's one of us missing mike uh mike
malak couldn't make it to puerto rico
because he um why couldn't he i didn't
invite him that's right like that's
right it's like that okay right so all
[ __ ]
all right all right
oh [ __ ] okay not like that no it's not
like that no i'm not going in no i can't
deal with these idiots i'm sorry
i can't handle the vibe there yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well we know where this guy's going
right i honestly don't i don't know what
the [ __ ] anyone's thinking anymore the
autumn
let's see
yeah i mean it's not a good sound but
we don't like him
yeah crush it
mike you laughed your way all the way to
the [ __ ] toilet
i love what ian labeled and mike shits
his gym shorts
[Laughter]
yeah rumor has it this guy shits his
pants all right i think that's com i
think it's beyond another rumor i think
we've told you i it's called
24-hour fitness yeah
gym shirts
zach is on the record now saying he has
seen and experienced mike [ __ ] his
pants
[ __ ] news to me
all right i'm out
yeah yeah okay here's an interesting one
logan paul
looking like a snack in this photo
uh this one goes way back man to i must
[ __ ] i'm a blueberry
now i'm a strawberry
purple you guys like purple oh
yeah that's right baby i'm a mother
freaking blueberry
thank you guys for watching as usual
dude
you remember that [ __ ]
i can't do it
i can't do it my voice doesn't hit that
pitch
i can't do it
it sounds like i can't get there
i can't hit it
i can go really low
no i'm a strawberry
all right let's see it's [ __ ] mickey
mouse dude
i mean it has a rice [ __ ] quality to it
yeah it's not a real laugh though which
makes it less
interesting oh we're getting
overwhelming d before
i would have put it a little bit higher
i mean i don't think so i think
the two goons at the bottom yeah
david dobrik
what's it oh god this one is
wait this one's age gated why
let me watch
it
why is this age district is just david
dobrik laughing for four minutes
okay
i don't because i don't know i don't
know what's in the video
play the sound bite
i mean you got more yeah you got any
more for us
i just have two
keep playing them
i mean you guys know what david dobrik's
slap sounds like right
you guys right here i'll watch the damn
thing
um i don't know why it's age gated
though
i'm gonna skip to them
nothing
you guys have that one where he's like
that was on tick tock where he's like
way laughing way too hard and it looks
super creepy
could someone have an edit of it i could
find let's see yeah let me let me see
that one because that video is pretty
interesting
the votes are in
yeah
david is sitting very comfortably at
[Music]
look at these goons at the bottom
here
um this video is uh
fetch me this oh god
wait how do i put this can i okay i can
kind of do this
i'm not sure how to show it on the
screen because it's
i have to show the whole discord [ __ ] it
yeah
so here is uh
this video has been going around of just
how david laughs way too hard here
yeah that's good
dude he's like
tripping balls when he laughs
fetch me this he's like
that's intense
yeah i like that
um
yeah he's a d though regardless and
finally we have our boy
kenneth nope kenneth nopeland
[Music]
[Laughter]
this guy is pure insanity man laughing
away
the associated press
said that joe biden is president
is he still laughing because joe biden
is still president
this guy thought that god would
intervene to make trump president but
man it's been like over 100 days and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ah
[Laughter]
i mean i like the sound bite if that's
what you're thinking about
but i hate kenneth i mean i despise him
it is
oh hey okay so what the [ __ ] do i know
i'm listen you know uh
i mean i do like
fair
okay kenneth you're up there
so this is it this is the final tally
they've coveted s dan myself ela jared
leto wendy williams and rice gum
congratulations
i feel good to be amongst the top right
i feel proud
[Laughter]
wendy definitely
deserves that one
abe how you feeling is the water cooled
down yet
yeah it's like cold now it's cold
yeah
a little pruned up but i'm good
you're gonna live stream after this
uh no i think i'm gonna get out of here
and try to get this out before lena gets
home
that's about all i've got oh this video
was sad i felt bad for this poor guy
this guy won jeopardy
okay you know about though there's the
white power sign where you do like this
hila
it means like it's so stupid yeah i've
only learned about it like in the last
year maybe i i don't really i guess it's
like w p right or or is it upside down
where's the p
the circle maybe don't do it
oh well listen if i'm white power then
i'm also the [ __ ] pope
people are going to take it out of
context as usual i am of course whatever
okay so what about it there's no
argument that i'm white power but you're
right i probably shouldn't have done it
because now it's going to be all over
the front page
so anyway this poor guy won three games
of jeopardy
and he did like this like three baby
going on three wins
and then everybody tore him up online
being like uh oh this guy's flashing
white power
you can tell that he was just like hey
flex in three wins
[Music]
from like he's like hey baby that's
three wins
and then he's like holy [ __ ] how is it
different than just a-okay yeah my whole
life i don't know they [ __ ] up they
they took over the [ __ ] i was like my
whole life this was like okay yeah i
mean i'll go up them purposes like hey
that's a-okay especially just right
israel like people use it everywhere
i've heard that it started
anymore like
you can do it it's just
i don't know i mean yeah it can the
context matters and also the whole
the whole point the reason that they did
that is intentionally taking something
that's innocuous and then using it as
their like little secret code and so
don't let them they can't take the okay
symbol okay symbol rules it's universal
like you said like you can't yeah they
can't have that they took it no they
can't have it this guy got busted
a white supremacist
oh
well what he did what was that
quartering
i am of course
a white supremacist wow
that's a stunning admission
um i don't know but the poor guy got
slammed
see
they hope they a group of 467 former
jeopardy contestants issued an open
letter wednesday
demanding a statement and disavowal
of his actions why did they organize so
fast
they've got a facebook group
the simply was holding up was co-opted
by white power groups
the three percenters
he and that's what i was going to say
he wasn't actually doing the okay thing
he was just doing three fingers on his
chest three and that is specifically i
guess the struggle of the three
percenters which is a uh
premises kelly donahue said i'm truly
horrified with what has been posted
about me on social media
the poor guy was just feeling good
with himself three wins that you know
that's that ain't no easy feat on
jeopardy
i'm not gonna read that thing but yep
shout out to his family
[Music]
um how are you feeling then
right pretty shitty
shout out to dan who made it into work
today after getting that vaccine shot
got my second shot yesterday and i am
feeling it today
i am feeling tomorrow you're gonna feel
great though
yeah
cause you're immune baby
yeah baby i'm immune baby i deserve to
be immune i deserve
oh today's my cheat day let's [ __ ] go
let's end the stream
what are we doing here still friday baby
it's friday baby
[ __ ]
come on baby it's the weekend [ __ ]
yeah baby friday baby yes get pumped up
it's the weekend let's get pumped up
baby friday [ __ ] friday yeah baby [ __ ]
i'm done
guys
have a great weekend
have a great weekend
that was fun yeah it was fun it's always
friday
yeah
friday baby yeah big thank you to carlos
for calling in that
win legendary that was life advice
really good a big moment and ben shapiro
ben shapiro legendary life advice
hopefully he gets his twitch account ban
lifted
and some really good advice for the
girls in the hot tubs too
from ben shapiro true sweet
and for a b and a hot tub and for a b
how's your water filtration system
are you are you bathing properly uh are
you taking um i just hope the couch that
this is propped on isn't broken yeah me
too
somebody asked if i'm p or m gang i am
moderna gang all the way baby
whatever you guys don't care about covet
anyway
nah sweden doesn't care they're like
whatever
ciao what do they say in sweden what is
it called when you guys have that snack
time with tea and snacks
yeah they're like [ __ ]
it it's fika time
oh yeah see you at fika
every day baby that's what it is to be
swedish right
tea and snacks [ __ ] i deserve
fika it's friday it can be a coffee
right or it's specifically well
the the
no no it's specifically a
treat like a
cinnamon ball uh bun something like that
i like it doesn't even have to be coffee
or deep
we don't do that there we go diet no
diet in sweden's are fat
they're just perfect they're out there
eating spika they're all chilling i mean
they they don't care about kovet ciao
going to fika
loves loves anfica
all right i'm gonna go have a feek of my
own
bye everybody have a great weekend take
care
thanks everybody
friday baby
see you next time
[Music]
you